welcome to the show my good friend tom
segura is here as you can see by this
poster that's over me
you guys love intros so you know him
from your mom's house
his famous stand-up uh stylings
ball hog your mom's house live and two
bears one cave which is
a show that he hosts and now he's here
get ready for conversational magic
[Music]
all right ready
it's so weird to see you as a guest on
someone's podcast even though it's mine
i know it's weird right it's so when was
the last time you were a guest on
someone that wasn't rogan
oh i did uh the smoking tire podcast
that's matt ferris positive car podcast
so i did his couple months ago a few
months ago yeah i bet that was so fun
it's fun because i love like he knows
everything and so i kind of i kind of
nerd out on that show
it's like me being a geek would you say
that's your main hobby
cars i mean i said fucking well i mean i
fucked pretty hard but
i think that uh he'll make that face
then between you both of you and your
wife's injuries i feel like you guys
fuck
side by side both on the bottom it's a
lot of side on side action yeah
it's just it's like swinging it's just
walruses they just lean over
so my least favorite thing about doing a
podcast is that moment
where before the podcast you're talking
to the host about some about like
finding parking and they're like save it
no save it and you're like no
this isn't the gold but there's this
don't save the chemistry yeah like we'll
not be able to find
five fucking more minutes of things to
talk about if you talk to me if you
think this is my big
podcast story then i'm just practicing
on you in the hallway like rehearsing
right now trust that i have a better
story than you saying i couldn't find
parking give me a fucking second man
but this is actually the first time i've
ever been like save it stop talking
yeah i just did that oh because so many
incredible things happened in the last
10 minutes
then things happened i don't know where
to start hey let's compliment the fact
that you have a great studio space
i'm very jealous for you to say that is
so is the
you are one of the only people's
opinions i respect thank you
and i know i'm just as surprised as you
are and
i i've been so on the train of smaller
is better smaller is better
i i have an ego i want people to think
it's like playing theaters i want to
know i play theaters and not clubs i
want to have a huge podcast studio
but i always learn from howard stern
every time you go on howard stern it's
like a studio apartment
but it makes the interview so much more
intimate yes yes
no you're i think you're a hundred
percent right the the
you learn it also when you guessed on
like talk shows like when you do
uh conan colbert you go in there on tv
you watch it and you're like oh this is
a huge and even though the
space in which the the set is in might
be enormous the sets are tight
right and the rooms are not like there's
not 500 people in that room you know
and there and it's all up here and you
realize it does you can look at somebody
you sit this close to talk show hosts
yeah and
i think it's the way to go i mean
there's there's no reason to have so
close yet so far away
there you go we'll get there though yeah
like i feel like talk shows
always just feel slightly weird to me
because why podcasts are far superior
because
i feel like i'm talking to you right now
yeah when i'm on a talk show i feel like
i'm trying to make them laugh oh it's
true
so i feel like every time i talk show
i'm like and then this and i'm doing
stand-up but also trying to get
them to attune and the weird thing too
now is and look
those hosts are amazing the staff
there's a very talent people work on
those but it's like
if you're wanting to promote something
knowing what you know now
you would go on a podcast that's right
you can talk about it for a couple hours
not like a five minute bit where which
especially if your second guest who
knows if they even watch till then so
they have
jessica lawrence jennifer lawrence right
on first of course then there's two
commercial breaks
and then you're like hey here's me it's
like if you're not the lead guest
it might not matter anyway you have to
knock it out of the park and hope that
that would go viral goes viral
next to a clip that your podcast is on
that's right so
wild yeah and i always feel so guilty on
talk shows promoting my podcast
because the host is so bummed that
they're still in a talk show deal
i know i'm like i'm free and they're
just like i mean conan's all in now
yes oh no i know he's just doing his
last thing and he's like yep podcast
right which is gonna work out so
you made out with emily oh yeah when was
this
is this true two weeks ago okay so you
guys
that was after you you pranked me but
that does bring me to something
christina's not here and probably on
oxycontin because of her fall
so i would like to talk about the fact
that i think you are incredibly hot
really yeah i am yes i think it needs to
be said
thank you whitney and there is this uh
thing
that i think guys even do like you guys
even on stage are like well i'm just the
guy like i'm not the adonis or like
there's this still this thing
the same way i'm learning that men don't
only want anorexic blonde girls
no that's we're holding on to that guys
have shown us we like butts
we like bodies women are so fucked it's
so cra here's the thing that
we're the ones that are you're sexist
yeah yeah and you guys are so fucked up
in that you don't realize that a
straight guy
would like they don't we don't care i
mean there's there's delusional
and sick and fucked up guy and like i'm
rebounding in my ego when i was a dork
so now i want to fucking
majority of guys they're like are so
thrilled
to have a live human woman
willing to like spend time with and also
most guys are lazy as shit and they're
like fucking
that ten is going to take so much work
and money i'd rather just go with the
person that
is grateful and frankly has the cushion
for the push and all that
because everybody is uh the same hot
after a year a model after a year that's
true
isn't a ten anymore if you know what i
mean because like i hang out her
bullshit is gonna come out like that
that that phase of you being wowed by
her
she thinks she's doing you a favor and
she might be but she knows it
so you're always going to be sweating
and it's not worth the
whatever half hour day you fuck or
whatever it is yeah no it's it's not
going to be worth it it's also
things that bother you about a fucking
six mm-hmm
the same same shit's gonna bother you
about the ten and you're gonna be like
oh like
the six is secretly at fucking ten six
secrets ten is secretly a fucking set
because the six
cares about you more yes and then ten is
fucking obnoxious
yeah and she's uh been you know uh
i think spoiled or something like i have
this thing where
sometimes i'm around a woman that's so
incredibly beautiful like in our
job uh or hollywood or whatever who's so
incredibly beautiful
and you're just like i don't even know
how you get through the grocery store
you know just like stunning all these
all these alien beauties the thing that
we think
is the fucking uh standard of beauty
because every people keep perpetuating
that even women women are like this is
the standard of beauty
says who says you says vogue like no one
guys have proved that this is not what
they are marrying so what why are we
still doing
a regular dude is so happy to just have
i swear to god
we are sexist against men like you guys
are showing that
we're actually except you're shallow
because christina's intent come on but
you think that i'm
christina seriously she has the kind of
face
christine is gorgeous that you get lost
in she has a
but what is the star she looks like a
like a a movie star from the 30s
that like her and you know because she's
what is that you bulgarian
hungarian yes she's got like um it's not
grace kelly but what's the big
she looks like do you know who um
saffron burrows is
she was in like the movie like troy she
always plays like
the grecian goddess look saffron burrows
you've seen her
she's like um i don't know she's older
than christina now
that's her yeah so she's got those yeah
yeah
she's got those she's got the big lips
but they're perfectly asymmetrical that
you can't
stop looking at them i got the i lucked
out obviously
in many ways i agree i remember thinking
that when i first saw you guys at
jerry's deli show
in on laurel canyon you're like what the
fuck like 15 years ago i was like oh
good she
she's getting somebody to write jokes
for her good for her i literally was
like good for her
i need to do that i literally was like
this is how you do it you date
uh-huh you know someone that's been
doing this yeah and he'll write you
jokes
and then you go married and cook yeah
she uh no genetically wait like when you
look at like
her dad and mom and relatives and like
how they're put together yeah and you're
like that like that guy's in his 70s you
know you know those people you're like
that guy's in the 70s
like that's her lineage her genetics
genetics are gonna like she's gonna
no but she's getting more beautiful
she's older yes which is that is and
then you look at the men
in my family and you're like oh is
everyone
dying because it doesn't look good
like there's guys that are 60 like is
that guy 85
yeah what's your lineage it's
mostly spanish on both sides okay um but
then there's some
french and irish uh mixed in on my dad
my mom's peruvian but it all goes back
to spain
my dad's like mostly spanish but has
french and irish
what are the advantages of being like um
the biological advantages of that i know
that hungarian i know why they have some
of those advantages you know a lot of
the bone structure stuff
this is uh they don't call me hoe rogan
for nothing
but the uh in tribal times we evolved
to have deeper set eyes okay because we
were
uh getting punched in the face so much
cool so people with deeper set eyes
ancestors probably were assholes that
got punched in the face all the time or
were dumb in the way that they
strategized well she's coming from this
mongolian fucking
ottoman empire and her cheekbones are
because her ancestors got punched in the
face they sure as fuck did
yeah and mine sat around and smoked and
drank coffee
yours were just in a hammock doing a
siesta although i guess you could say
that some of them were
maybe uh savages in their own right but
they're lazy like conquistadors you know
like
showed up with 80 people and flew and
they knocked out a whole fucking village
but wouldn't you argue that people that
are more relaxed by nature or that
you know french and spanish who hat take
all of august off and they have siestas
and they go home early and they sure as
fuck dude but shouldn't they have less
stress and therefore live longer i i
would think
they drink more
i just know what i'm looking at i've
i've seen photos and i've met people in
my family i'm like i'm going to die
quickly
i just know it i just know it's no
you're not i know it's going to be
you have avoided death at least six
times the last year
so i i won't hear it yeah and plus you
already said i'm looking good right you
said i'm i'm here's the thing
was yours i want to be really clear now
that christina's not around she's not
around
because i know she's she's very
threatened by me listen go for it
and by the way i am also wearing your
husband's shirt yes
i'm wearing his merch not yours so now
you know whose side i'm on and what my
plan
is to destroy your marriage she'd
probably be psyched
frankly this guy thinks fences cost 250
i need to leave it i mean i am
so worried about how you spend your
money really when
kind people get really really successful
and wear comics before
yeah i mean you're this fence you're
trying to buy it
i've done some dumb shit i'm not gonna
lie what is the
the silliest waste of money you've done
and we'll get back to how hot you are
because if you tell me how much money
you have you'll get hotter
okay i'm trying to think of one that's
like really stupid
you know um because the stupid things
i've spent money on
i don't consider the car purchase is
stupid because like so investments well
they're not investments they really are
toys uh i mean you can buy a classic or
a car that's good like the rare
car that will hold value you know these
types of broncos is bronco that rare car
well generally speaking no there's some
old broncos that um
people are a lot of times they're like
restoring them
modifying them scamming customers you
have bronco
uh you know i reached out to you because
i want them one so badly oh i told you
the one that i wanted the old the
teal one no the navy one the one that uh
i saw the one that blake had
because he had a really cool old-school
one like sheldon
by the way playing basketball we've
we've learned that's not your strength
it cost you a hundred thousand dollars a
year to play basketball
you know he's a good friend of both of
us can we please do a video of you
playing
blake at basketball sure as your
comeback sure a comeback video
i want to get back to your uh uh money
wasting money your hotness uh blake
griffin i made a movie that blake
griffin was in yes i remember
and and i also want to ask you about
your acting career uh and
that and why we still feel the need to
act as comedians and podcasters why do
we still
you're really on point with this yeah
because i think about it all the time
why well we'll get to it can we get to
it because it's it's something that i
think our fans like i'll tell you
something that i thought
we were doing our lives pursuing
the woman that has said no to us since
high school we are chasing the dream of
being actors when we get when we lose
money doing it
the movies don't even fucking come out
no one sees them nobody cares no one
cares we're taking our time and energy
away from the people that do care yeah
to put out something that you know then
we have to press forward and then we
gotta talk about our practice like so i
want to get to that
that uh why we love something so much
that doesn't love us back what are we
trying to prove
yeah um so do i start with money no you
start with uh uh blake griffin was in a
movie i
did and i just want to say that he is
he's got a unique brain
that is so incredible and i and a big
part of my life right now
is surrendering to people being so good
at something yeah
and going this is what you're doing it's
awesome right and if you can't do this
who gives a shit you can do that and me
also going
you know what i have to try so hard to
get this to happen yeah
it doesn't come easily to me i'm 38 i'm
going to cut my losses
i'm not going to learn but do you ever
look at do you ever look at the thing
that doesn't come easy and go well
that's the challenge then that's what i
that's what i want to pursue because it
doesn't come easy i'm good
i'm not going to chase the man that
doesn't like me because it's a challenge
i'm at a point where the ch
a challenge doesn't like get me off it's
not like with relationships
um that's wisdom wisdom is saying like
i'm not going to
make you i don't care if it's platonic
or romantic it's like or
you know a club booker who's like you're
not for me okay like because if i'm
doing that it's an addiction yeah so i'm
now being
pathological and what's the difference
between wisdom and knowledge
what what's the difference between
wisdom and knowledge what's the
difference um i don't know neither do i
okay
oh i thought you were like neither of us
have wisdom that's why we don't know
but i heard someone ask that question to
me like once at a thing and i was like
huh i i want to know the answer to that
oh okay because
it really felt like you were about to
school me i was ready for it that was on
purpose okay i can't i don't act in
movies anymore
on the show yeah but i do think the
wisdom of the knowledge of every time
i've
texted this man it's gone poorly every
time i've tried to
do this audition thing and test 50 times
and not get it it's not gone well that's
the knowledge
because i have the data that this has
never worked it's never worked it's
never worked
the wisdom is i'm not i'm not gonna
do it again because my brain i don't
know if it's attic thinking or just like
ambitious tenacious person thinking but
i go well i just got rejected ten
times the next one's when i'm gonna get
it yeah of course i'm due
of course for it i'm due for a miracle
yeah so i'm gonna try again
yeah gambling app that's gambling
addiction 101 yeah i mean
you have to be a little sick to
even try well to be a comedian for sure
too
i think to be an actor even more like
that you know i mean to be able to deal
with
the rejection and trying to pursue that
career and being told you're not good
enough and stand up for it and keep
going
because part of it's pathological is
going the same way if you're in a bad
relationship or guys being
you know emotionally abusive or a
woman's being emotionally abusive you go
ah she was just hungry
yeah yeah he was just tired i was
putting too much pressure on him i had
to
i said we also do that with work i did
that with
auditions and stuff for years of being
like ah they wanted to hire diverse
yeah ah you know what i was you know
they
i looked like their ex-girlfriend and
then i get like i make excuse that
i make the no something that makes
me awesome
i was too funny i was too tall yeah but
only that we all do that
for for everything like you you have to
say those things
to exist to survive to survive in the
world
so and it doesn't matter whether it's a
a guy
or a job or an audition like you know
but i think that
i mean your mogul status
in in domination in podcasts
you fucking were to me i mean besides
joe rogan because he was already he had
was done with tv he wasn't really doing
movies he's such an anomaly
you're one of the first people he also
has mma
like he's got this other whole crowd
he's got a hole you are the first person
you know what i'm going to fucking do my
plan b
i don't know if or like no i'm going to
sit around and take matters into my own
fucking hands i
never thought i would be doing this i i
never ever ever
thought my first of all i never thought
i'd be doing stand-up so
i i came out here to be a comedic some
people still think you shouldn't
they are friendly there's a lot of
people who are not on board
and uh and i'm comfortable with all
those people that's a great place to be
i think that's true do you realize the
reason i'm with my boyfriend
is he was my critical care vet when my
dog was dying and he saved my dog's life
but he had my number
and we were texting about my dogs and
then at 10 o'clock on a monday he texted
me
hey i'm watching ball hog uh saguaro's
the funniest comedian
i'll show you the text really yes and
then i was like we started
texting personally and now we're
together well i just told somebody too
because they go like you know when
people go like you suck you're not funny
i'm like yeah
i'm at the point though where i go
that's like i would never
ever say that well i'm just saying that
your wife for sure
but i would never um try to convince
somebody
otherwise of their opinion about me in
any regard personally or professionally
i just go like
that's cool i'll just play to the people
who do enjoy it yeah no but also
i don't i don't get lenny bruce that
doesn't mean other people don't exactly
that
like here's the thing like not all for
you if everyone loves you you're
probably
it's a problem you know what i'm saying
that's where that's when you're doing
sound effects and humping stools
so and also like you know to me
comedians all we do is fight about like
our right to say things in first
amendment but then when
and and i have the right to do this and
not this and then when people say i
don't like this or i don't think it's
funny we're like you can't say that yeah
i know wait a second because we're
we're so we're such people we're so
fucking we're such don't get me started
on the fact
that i believe we have started cancel
culture because all we did is complain
about it when it's a very small thing
and would have probably just gone away
just fuel it up we talked about it no
one's letting us speak 20 people on
twitter
now we've made it the very thing if
somebody goes to cancel you right now
like this week what would it be well i
don't know what it would be or
whether but like don't you feel like
knowing like
having witnessed what you've seen and
everything that you would just like just
come back here and just do another
podcast tomorrow just keep going go to
your shows and be like
i'm just not going to unless it was like
the crime of the century something
so horrific like you just be like um
keep going
i think i have two answers uh and then
i'm gonna make sure we get back to all
the questions um
because i blue ball people on the
podcast i asked 50 questions and they
got digressed and we never found out all
right right and it's
it's so fucking bushy well yeah because
we didn't yeah yeah okay because i know
a lot of people want to talk about how
handsome you are
right um uh and then what was the other
one acting
acting because i'm blown away by your
your acting skills like acting you want
to be here right now stuff like that
um but being cancelled
like you know yes my
my mind has changed in the la and here's
the other thing comedians forget to
change their minds once they get new
information
you know yes as if first of all changing
your mind with new information
is wisdom that's wisdom that is wisdom
and
like the you know if you go like hey
let's explore your opinions at 21. and i
was like man if i had the same opinions
now at twenty that if you married the
person you were with the 21
i mean what are we doing it would be
insane what are we doing
yeah we fired the editor of vogue uh she
had just been hired
this one very bothers me so much and i'm
i'm furious that she was fired i'm
curious that she's
so upset unless she was like guys i
don't want to fucking weather this storm
i don't want to be the martyr that shane
that changes the game because she very
well
could have been the one that goes you
know what i'm i'm not leaving i'm
staying but she might have just gone i
don't want to drag my family through
this or whatever
you realize what like basically happens
every time
cancer culture is happening like what
we're basically going
as human beings we're going i want to
talk about the worst shit
like the worst day or the worst thing
you've ever said or done
and like and publicly shame you forward
i understand if
as if me and you and everybody else
don't have a worse thing that you've
said or done also why
are we not using our fucking noggins and
going
this has always happened right species
have
we have always done this it's not new
it's not so we're treating it like it's
that to me is the most insane thing
we're acting like there weren't public
square hangings we're acting like there
weren't
roman coliseums we're acting like public
shamings haven't always happened
true this is just a new iteration of it
you know so
so we want to blame like the left and
the right and it's like we've always
been this shitty
yeah we've all it's true we've always
been this shit it's been this shitty and
i just don't understand why we don't
like
and i do in the female brain i have a
scene about it which is that
the part of the reason we're so wired to
rubber neck is
number one we're trying to learn how to
avoid being shamed in the future so
we're studying it
and then the other thing is that we um
uh are trying to when we point at other
people
i believe when we point one finger at
everyone else we point three at
ourselves
that's what we say like in programs sure
but when we point fingers at other
people
that's our way of saying i'm innocent it
doesn't work
it's an old strategy that doesn't work
because my thing is if you cancel you're
next oh i
i feel like when people go oh we're
coming for you why haven't you um you
know i've been asked like why don't you
give an opinion on
this or that and i'm like look that
person who's getting dragged right now
they don't need me to additionally pile
on like if the public
have the people that have been canceled
yeah were people that tried to cancel
well who the fuck's this guy let's look
at the skeletons in their closet like
you're
you are uh and i think that this is
where things are really getting fucked
up is
is in this next generation or younger
people or whoever's doing it
you are setting a standard that you
yourself will never be
so you're fucking yourself in the future
by going instead of going
okay i've done something like that let's
not cancel for this because then i'm
next
just know that the standard you're
setting for no one's ever allowed to
have made a mistake in their teens
it's crazy bitch you're not going to
have custody of your kids in 20 years
because you're having to live up to the
standard you helped create
yeah i mean the the the publisher editor
girl
the the one that got fired before her
first day you know the conde nast ones
it it's so depressing that that
what if she made those fake tweets so
she could get out of that fucking stupid
job that'd be hilarious
maybe she got there like dude this is
awful and that one of the things that
happened
more to the point you're making is that
when
she was like i'm out and they were like
she's out
people at conde nast and i think even
specifically at that public teen vogue
a couple employees tweeted things so
people found that we're like thank god
just they tweeted things like woo
like that's something and then they went
and found those
girls tweets that's what i'm saying i
found them making like
racist tweets and they're like oh so but
to me only people that point fingers
yeah have skeletons in their closet sure
because what you're doing is going don't
look at my mistakes right
look at her look look over there and
they haven't learned yet
when you point one finger you point
through it yourself and you're fucking
next and you better be
you squeaky clean to me this girl
the vogue girl should have not only kept
her job
but we should have gone you know what
she's even more qualified for this job
because she's writing a joke a fucking
joke i mean teen vogue
uh for teenagers yeah this is the exact
person to go hey
i've made a mistake yeah exactly this is
how you come back from a mistake here's
an example for
young teenage girls i'm an example that
you can fuck up
and handle it with dignity and grace you
can still go for that public job
you can still run for office you can
still because to me
if you're reading teen vogue all you're
learning is well i tweeted something bad
two years ago so i'll never get the
career i want
yeah and you can't reach for your dreams
because you're like i made a mistake
when i was 12.
imagine the girl who's like they when
it's also when you read her tweets that
they got upset about
it was like so you're like i didn't know
i mean so it wouldn't even raise an
eyebrow you're like this is what you're
going to have time where there was the
you know stopping it was like it doesn't
it none of it matters
but i i'm i'm curious when humans are
going to learn
by this negative see the pattern yeah
that it's like you are setting a
precedent that you yourself cannot live
up to
and you know when when do we protect
each other
and when do we not like that's a
fascinating thing for me because yeah
i could have you know not that i'm like
the end all you know uh
i try to shut my mouth about this kind
of stuff but like when do we go
hey like i did actually i don't think we
showed the picture
but i want to experiment with outing
myself on something
and see what happened and that's
interesting
because i think a lot of it is if you
get to if
if you admit it first i think a lot of
what people don't like is that it was a
secret
oh we found this exactly but if you go
hey i did this stupid thing 10 years ago
it's i'm so curious
you know that i have a cancel reel ready
that's already cut
where is it that's it
for today so get ready that's in my
office where
like when they dig up the whatever thing
they don't like about me
um i have like they could have pulled
something from yesterday's
house they could have pulled anything
they could have pulled anything so so i
do want to talk about that because i
want to talk about um when you said this
stuff about
what would i be canceled or how what i
think about canceling
and getting new information changing
your mind yeah so
a year ago i would say nothing matters
canceling isn't real unless you've
committed a crime things are different
now
so a year ago don't fucking address it
let it go right it'll blow over you're
going to make it bigger by talking about
it
definitely you're invincible if you have
a good heart i believe that
if people this is a year ago though i
thought this a year ago maybe six months
ago
okay and then uh people should know what
comedy is
if they think that if they believe this
canceling thing if they think you're an
asshole now they were never your fans in
the first place
you're not losing your fans yeah your
fans know you and they're going he was
fucking kidding
of course there was an you know but
two weeks ago i went on joe rogan and
a week ago there was an article in usa
today that said
whitney come debunked that whitney
cummings
drinks baby blood
i had joked about on joe rogan and they
debunked it they debunked that you drink
baby blood
because you're saying that they said we
we contacted her reps and she was in
fact joking
it was a correction piece so because you
know the other thing is that like you
really have to search
search for journalists now like it's not
they're not
people don't write news articles anymore
whitney cummings
admitted to using children's blood to
avoid aging
wow this is a news story this is a real
news story two and on followers say
hollywood and washington elites run the
child sex trafficking ring
and i joked whitney cummings and joe
rogan joking around
dude this is what i do with baby blood
for my skin
you do that you do baby blood yeah the
adrenal chrome i have a sprinkler i
spray it all over my face
and they're like news my guess and this
is why my mind has changed
yeah my guess is i know
that these outlets make money when
people click on a story
totally and rogan's name is huge q
anon is huge so it used to be like
i don't care if i'm fucking canceled but
now that that
is my number one google search like it's
the kind of thing and because
q anon has gotten so much stronger and
what they the power they do have now is
that they can
mobilize even if they were never fans of
your you before they they don't like
that you made a baby or whatever they
don't like something you did
they can mobilize and 5 000 people can
email manscaped and say
i can't be advertising this person's
show they don't know the difference
between a customer
that is i'm not buying your product
anymore yeah because you advertise with
thomas
psycho yeah yeah it it 5000 complaints
is 5 000 complaints yeah
they don't know if they're sane or not
they're all coming from earthlings and
yahoos and that shit really works
and that works yeah so there is a very
real
public forum cancellations is not what
i'm talking about
i'm talking about these people banding
together to email our sponsors
and take our livelihood it's changed
yeah
that's definitely that's look i i i
can't first of all it's just it blows my
mind that
it is clearly a click-bait thing but to
just be like yeah i use baby blood
now that news now that you have taken
the jobs of all the journalists
you podcasts have taken the money from
and all they need to reference podcasts
in order to have popular
news stories it's true so we they love
hate us
where do you where do you go for news
when you want when you want
i ask this to everyone on the podcast
because i
literally i think i go to twitter i go
to twitter i
follow the topic i follow all the news
sites uh uh the guardian
cnn has become people magazine like i
cannot believe
how because you we we're close in age
and it's like i
i try to tell people you're just pushing
that's just me
um i look older i give it to you but uh
the uh yeah i do that baby blood
the people they gotta get on it the the
thing is that people don't
they don't realize if they're like you
know 30 or younger that that
when we were like growing up cnn was
really was like it was just an anchor
reading prompter
there was you didn't know their
personalities they read prompter they
cry but i mean like these guys like now
oh now
and like they're like i had a latte like
the fuck are you talking about what you
had for lunch
like this was the a respected like all
day news thing it was fascinating
because you just get news
at the news hour and then this was like
in the 90s and early 2000s
we should have known shit was hitting
the fan because they started doing opens
like a marvel movie with an eagle
swooping by going to
nights well yeah dramatic news my
dramatic news and then we started to
like dramatize and
sell started but it started there's a
fucking live feed from the war right now
which was you know and then they played
and then you know
the thing that really pisses me off is
when they just run
if a celebrity committed suicide they
run it over and over again knowing
that the more you cover a suicide the
more likely people are to commit suicide
because it glamorizes it yeah really is
that
oh 100 yeah so there's this whole thing
of like when anthony bourdain
committed suicide and kate spade and i
think one other peop
person a lot it was like stop posting
about it and when
comedians and actresses and or actors
they want
likes or they want to chime in on some
of the committed suicide and say i loved
him so much like you're actually
it's called a suicide cluster which is
when people that are depressed or
whatever and they see
rest in peace they go oh there's peace
if i get you know
they start seeing oh my god you become
famous like everyone would like me so
much more if i was just dead and look at
all these people
celebrating the suicide in a way that's
fucked that's when you're like oh what's
my ethical
uh responsibility do i want to like just
get in on it so that i'm
yeah and people don't think and a lot of
people like well if i don't post about
it they're gonna think i don't care no
one fucking cares
yeah i i when when anthony bourdain's
commit suicide i'm not like how come she
didn't post about it i'm not thinking
about you
no i know you know so they're all are
there all these
like ethical breaches that these
news organizations absolutely know
they're fucking violating right now
but they they're going out of business
we've known for years
that i didn't know about how suicide
we've known for years that
you if you glorify like a mass shooter
and somebody does like a horrific crime
you start
giving like you're just fueling that
attention that they wanted and
it doesn't actually serve serve the the
the masses the audience isn't benefited
but they don't
they don't it doesn't matter they in
this is it's always been
like like there's and look i don't blame
journalists and people that work at news
companies if i'm if i'm in a news
corporation
and a thousand people are getting fired
every year because they're getting less
and less profitable
and more and more people you know are
showing that journalism is a fucking
joke now
um and it's a difference between me
feeding my kid
yeah and posting something about suicide
like if it means i'm gonna make that
bonus like i understand people have to
make shitty decisions
the fucking one of the murdocks you know
left fox news somebody's
gonna can make insane amounts of money
because he didn't want to be part of
what they were doing did you see
succession i watched uh first season i i
didn't
and i didn't stop watching because i
didn't like the show it's one of those
things that you yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought i thought
it was great uh jessica yellen is where
i get my news so jessica yellen
she's been on the podcast she came on
with moz when that
iranian saga was going on i'm like i
don't know how to talk about this but
they
just came and talked about it she was at
abc and cnn
and she was so horrified by the way that
they made their news decisions and the
way that they exaggerated things and she
left and she now doesn't she has like
a million followers on instagram and she
it's called news not noise
yeah and she she has that's what we need
she has access to all the fucking news
people have the quotes and she clears
she makes it clear she's talks into
camera
and explains what everything means the
the only places i've seen
where i'm like okay this is new like
actual what news used to be i guess
is like pbs you don't know what the fuck
those people do they just are like
they stare blankly and read like thank
you the ap
yeah they read the exactly and then i
also noticed that when
when i travel and you get cnn
international it's like
it's completely different than cnn it's
made for adults it's made for adults
it's usually like uk or hong kong based
and they just like
here's news you're like why don't they
put this feed on like
well because i and it's also amazing
when you go to other countries and you
see their newspapers and you're like
why do we have the why is ours why does
ours look like the the comic strip
section and there's look like the adult
section because cnn is supposed to be
hilarious
i don't want to fucking laugh during
this shit get ready to put noise
cancelling headphones on
everyone because if i've told you well
a hundred thousand times i've told you
all hundred thousand one times
benton is uh has written my dialogue for
me
and why are you laughing
do you realize it's funny why is this
funny to you
because it's me trying to write the way
i think you sound
and then i'm i'm like who talks like
this
is this me i don't like moves so you're
one of those writers that
makes everyone talk in your voice but i
really want you to say this so that's
why i wrote it
if i told you once comma well dot dot
dot
chances are i've told you more than once
that i love
ritual like i've said i've used the
vitamins for years
and now they offer a protein powder am i
this unfunny and boring
rituals new essential protein powder is
a delicious plant-based protein powder
reimagined by a team of scientists
and offered in three premium
formulations in distinct life
stages can you read that again whitney
the good for you team
here tried the product and yeah
we'll just let's see how that went
i'm not even joking with you i wrote
this at truly 3 a.m
this ritual one
well yeah like it was i was just saying
it out loud like this typing like
talking to myself
oh god
hi and welcome to good food welcome
welcome do you often find that you need
to be healthy
hold on my potatoes hello amazing that
sounds just everything you need in one
scoop
we normally make our smoothies like this
we will show you now
step one add liquid to the blender
we're using oat milk not a sponsor
look away from it doesn't matter you
know what i love about using ritual
take the tab off water what's that
it's that multi-vitamin company that i
know and love
oh me too that's disgusting
and protein powders can be very
intimidating is that enough milk do you
think
grandma's right now let's add our no no
this is how we normally make a shape not
how we make a ritual shape
oh oh now
this is not an app it is great okay i
like to add blueberries
just split the pineapple no split it oh
i wish i had an easier smoothie to make
waiting waiting waiting oh no the
blender is stuck
what's wrong with blender can i even
drink this smoothie
no it's chunky benton don't
hey wait a minute i have a better idea
what's up
let's use the original essential protein
powder oh with ritual all you need is
one scoop in 8 to 12 ounces of
any cold liquid oh look the cold liquid
grace look at that
let me add it to the blender this is
incredible
i'm cooking while we blend that up let
me tell you some great things about
ritual it's a complete amino acid
profile
it's sugar-free it's free of soy gluten
and major allergens
it's being it's friendly no artificial
flavor
no gmo first party
[Music]
[Applause]
these key ingredients are sourced from
all over the world to help fill gaps and
support protein synthesis
ages 18 to 49. we are those ages
we're 19. i'm not barely let's try it
oh it smells good oh it's not like
cookie dough
i love it
grace you should try something oh it's
good
wasn't that delicious ritual
ritual used
ritual it's really good ritual.com slash
whitney okay we're rolling
i'm just gonna put one tiny screw in
this smoothie
well um
everyone used to make videos in high
school for school projects
yeah it's literally like old school
youtube we just got our first check we
moved into our empty mansion we have no
furniture
we have a fold-out table and a sponsor
and a vitamix
and a positive attitude for
tomorrow as much as today made with
nutrients to support
bones brains and muscles clean
plant-based formulas specifically
created to support nutrient needs of
different
ages stages parentheses 18 plus
pregnancy postpartum and 50 plus so all
the time right
is that all the stages sometimes you're
before 18. so why not shake up your
ritual
to try making something new less scary
ritual offers a money-back
guarantee if you're not 100
in love plus my listeners get a 10
off thing during your first three months
just visit ritual.com
whitney add essential protein also today
that's ritual.com
whitney it's gonna be on the screen also
so just it's on the screen read it
let's take a break to shave our legs
with billy razors
billy gives me the slickest closest most
comfortable
shave in fact everyone on our team uses
billy razors you know why because they
work
you used them right benton i did use
them and it was an experience
which i luckily recorded for you
what a coincidence oh you know i always
wanted to be a billy baddie
but shaving is just so difficult like
i'm sure it's easier for all these
beautiful
women that i do this podcast with but
like i thought it was gonna be really
difficult for me
but billy made it so easy so i stepped
in the shower with my belly shave cream
lathered up my hair little leg and
watched this razor glide right through
and now
i am a billy baddie emerging from the
waters like aphrodite herself
these flick legs
here oh there we go and then oh here i
am oiling up my
newly shaven legs all over lathering up
and here i am seductively eating this
banana thanks to billy razor
because with billy you are an ig model
walk with a waddle
[Music]
so that was fun wasn't it wow
thank you for sharing that with us i was
so excited i got to use that
tick tock line ig model a lot with a
waddle that's all i wanted to do was say
that
the whole thing was just so i could say
that one thing shout out to her wrote
that song
you've inspired me to give a speech
which is
the best razor out there for days when
you want extra smooth shave it's called
billy
there's no pink tacks uh no visit to the
drugstore just pink panties
pink pants i saw those pink pantaloons
you
need to go too sorry i'm literally
speechless you guys you guys can go to
mybilly.com
to get their starter kit for just nine
dollars it's so affordable includes
their award-winning
razor two refill blades and cult
favorite
magnetic holder two refill blades but
alan you do one blade to shave my whole
body audience is
all of your hair in my pool like i have
so many questions i shaved my
you saw me shave my legs in your shower
you're in the clog the shower not the oh
god i gotta go and i collected it all
and made you a small wig
a benton doll i'm looking for a
wig for mona to match mine we have
different hair i'm gonna red hat
to express a little love for our show
please go to mybilly.com
whitney it's a small way you can support
us while getting the best razor you will
ever own it's just nine dollars and to
get your starter kit
plus free shipping always go to
mybilly.com
whitney spelled my b i l l i e dot com
slash whitney be that beach
what do you have over there i have a uh
ice blender would you like one i got two
it's a coffee ice blended
i've never had it it's i've neither have
i had a hazelnut one but i didn't uh
i didn't do the self-care today and now
i'm in a
jam you're a jam have you ever eaten on
your podcast and when you do how many
viewers do you lose i'm sure i'm sure i
have i remember i
i commented i gave you shit about yes
they don't forget that's exactly what i
was i was like who was it that the game
we should be doing
topher grace comes on the show he's like
eating a burger he's never done a
podcast
he's an old friend no i kind of have
some people that like have never done
podcasts and they'll start eating or
doing something crazy i'm like
like or they'll start hitting the table
when they're talking with like a
bracelet and i'm like oh
like i'm so lucky to have them how dare
i push it of course of course
but yeah topher grace sat down and was
like i'm starving can we order food and
i was like of course
i figured it after and he's just like
like brings out a chicken sandwich and
just like
anyway so let me direct the conversation
a bit
i think i was there the first night you
did stand up is that right i got
murder you got murdered no i didn't
realize you got murdered i didn't like
murder because i was just
doing the instagram scroll and i see it
and i was like hey cool to have your
guests eat or something
i mean it was like it was like a
two-hour pocket he didn't start
three maybe he didn't start eating until
like two and a half hours in that was
the only takeaway yeah yeah i know
people they
they murder you for stuff or like you
have a sniffles or something stop
sniffing like people
just about your sniffs or oh i had to
sign it drinking on mike
so this is also this is is this kind of
healthy soy or oat milk
okay there's definitely sugar in it it's
not healthy i'm just all right it's a
pick-me-up
all right okay it's a pick-me-up because
you were not able to self-care today
correct and now i'm acting i'm like why
do people treat us like children i'm
eating my
my afternoon milkshake you know i was
just making fun of uh somebody was
asking me
about like because somebody asked me for
a picture i took a picture and i go
at a restaurant and they they're talking
about like do people
like fuck with you and i go you know
what what happens all the time people
think they're
being clever is i'll walk out of a place
and someone's like hey hey
tom and they go uh you know they hold
the phone they go
like this and i go yeah and they go no
no uh will you take a picture of us
and then they're like and then you know
what i do every time i go sure
and then they're like
like i tricked you do you know how many
times that's been done to me and by the
way now i'm not you've got your chance
for the picture
yeah with me they're like but i you
thought i was gonna ask you for a
picture i was asking you to take a
picture of me
yeah that's an old disease joke that he
did on conan
cool so so to me i do think like i'm
learning
anyone that thinks they're being funny i
will laugh at them
and i'll go oh that's crazy thank you so
much and then i'm gone
gone so i was never a dick yeah you know
i never but
i i also when someone comes up wants a
photo i just go put in selfie
put in selfie get it and move on but
it is amazing how many people go can you
take a selfie of us
oh yeah to you i had i this has happened
more than once in airports
people come up to me like hey my phone
is charging can you take a photo
on your phone and just email it to me
email it to me it happened at least
three four times
i did it i did it i did of course i did
was i can say no i like the easiest way
out of this is to just do it
the easiest way out of this is to just
do it louie used to say
remember uh he said something
fascinating he doesn't like taking
photos
so he said when someone approaches him
for a photo in the airport or whatever
he always says i won't take a photo with
you but i will talk to you for five
minutes
yeah he's never been taken up on it
really not once
they're like oh i'm good never mind yeah
and this was like
five years ago he said it when he's when
before all the drama yeah
that's really interesting they're like
i'm not interested in that i just wanted
to sue literally he's like they'd be
like
hmm and walk away like you could talk to
them in five minutes i mean
i would have taken them up on that as a
fan that's crazy um
people i one thing i hate is like being
yelled at
like from it like when someone's like
top like that and i've been walking with
people
and they're like hey the guy's yelling i
go yeah i know it's my favorite thing to
do is pretend
well people feel an entitlement to me
that i have to understand
what i'm putting out well i think it's
interesting
it's always about what you put out and
one thing i noticed is that i used to
like
really lean into i actually feel like i
started to live
a narrative that i put out more so than
i wanted to
which was that i like to be alone and
don't bother me
and i i think i started to try to
be that i started to just be like you
know i don't like to be
i don't i don't like meet and greets and
i don't like this stuff
the truth is like i like people and i
like being around people and
you know i like being alone at times
you know like if we were in uh i don't
know on the road and like in houston
and i'd be like yeah let's go to
breakfast and then you know at some
point i'd be like i'm gonna go
to my room right but i started to say it
so much about like being alone that i
feel like i was trying to be alone
more than i wanted to be does that make
sense i also think this could be some
subconscious
like darwinian survival instinct that
you didn't even realize you had
because people including us were not
spring chickens anymore
i just did like 10 shows in
four cities like or whatever weekend i
was doing the four o'clock show on
saturday yeah then the 11 30 show i was
doing like two show like i
and i was like oh stand up is
really draining it's exhausting people
when you're like i don't do meet and
greets it's like
well after you've done two hour shows
it's exhausting which are
really physically draining and then
you've spent the whole day
out people pleasing or hanging out like
people are like well you just go on
stage and fuck around it's like no
no if i'm doing three shows a night i'm
not leaving my hotel room or even
talking on the phone or texting three's
a nightmare
three show days i can't believe i did it
i won't do it
because there were all these well see
there were all these small venues that i
booked
back when comedy clubs were going out of
business and we were like we gotta book
these guys we gotta go to helium we got
to go to
you know uh the improvs like they're
going to go out of business we got to go
to
mcgoobies in baltimore which i just did
like they're going to go out of business
yeah and the big theaters weren't open
and our only options in december were
like okay fine
i'll do six show like we gotta get our
reps in
yeah you have to i don't wanna go to a
theater and just fucking suck and then
you realize
actually if you been playing theaters
for a while and then you go to these
club weeks you're like
this is this is the most fun like the
clubs are so fun
always right now they're they're a
little rowdy people are a little feral
they're excited to be out i think
security people aren't sure if they're
allowed to approach people because of
covid no one's really tapping people on
the shoulder
like a lot of people got kicked out in
texas oh yeah all the shows i've done
have people
kicked out it's been people are like
storming the stage they're
like it's just kind of been a i think
you know people during the set we're
just looking at each other being like
yeah oh my god that happened to me one
and i'm like
you guys know i you you can't talk while
i'm talk like yeah i have to
keep they haven't been out they haven't
been out in a while so everyone's a
little rusty but
i i mean i'm 38 now i cannot believe tom
that we used to do this
i did 10 shows in spokane i think in
four days i
and then i was like dude i used to do i
mean not i wasn't selling out 10 shows
back then but
and we used to get up at 4 00 a.m to do
radio
it's yeah till 10. it feels like 50
years ago
right i used to take a red eye go in
tuesday night lamb wednesday morning do
the jiggles and
the yeah and you're actually doing this
you were like producing and
starring on television shows and i
thought about it because i i googled you
so hard last night did you feel it i
felt it
you are like a the king of morning show
news oh yeah i used to fuck around how
did you how did you even have the
energy to do that at 5am like i
i ended up having to make it fun for
myself that's how i did dj dad mouth
because i
i was doing i used to hate you know
so much and right like a lot of radio
stations if you go like
jiggles they'll be like god what a
nightmare not that i was difficult i
would just show up be like what
and they're like hey it's your time to
shine like shut up
like i don't even want to be like i was
just like and the club would be like
what are you doing i was like i don't
want to do this
then i would just be driving the time
you've already sold out and they're
keeping you going just
to promote their when that started to
happen when the when the sellouts when i
would arrive and they're like the
weekend sold out but tomorrow we're
doing this i was like why are we doing
that
and they're like because they're using
you yeah of course and i was like okay
so i showed up in me nuts
i showed up with like a gold chain and
like a
fake fur thing and they go what the fuck
is this
and i was like i'm a dj and they were
like okay
and so i would go on and they would be
like and i would tell
because i would be like a young guy
working like the chiron you know
and i was like hey i go put in put in dj
dadmouth instead of
like comedian and the guy be like oh
okay so and then i would tell the
the person like introduce me this way
and they they're like they think it's
like oh this is fun
so i tell them and then they're like all
right coming here uh dj dad mouth
and i look at the club and they'd go
like what are you like off screen like
what are you doing
and then i would tell them i was like
you know i don't really care about the
way you're called hyenas
don't make fun of my name yeah i don't
think if i went and i would go
on on the show i would go you know i
don't really focus on comedy anymore
they were like what and i go it's all
about the after party like i'm dj in
this club
after the show so you know and then and
the club like why would you say that i'm
like the shows are sold out who cares
like people fucking characters
and by the way that became whether you
know this or not
people would say tom score dude have you
seen his like local
news yeah and sorry guys and
i feel like watching that i was like oh
this is when podcasting started
oh that silliness like when he was the
star
right jen i'm saying like he's cut out
for
some people aren't you know i came out
as non-binary on one of those
and um this was before it was like even
in the zeitgeist
like i just learned it was like 2015.
you know i mean like it was just like a
phrase no one even knew really
unless you were really dialed in still
they most people yeah and so i was on
this i think it was in jacksonville i
was on this morning show
and it was like a real karen you know as
the host and uh
she was like she goes you have a big
announcement i go yeah you know i go
last year you know i came out as like
bisexual
now i'm coming out as non-binary and she
was like okay
and she you could see her look off
screen and she's like what's that all
about
and then i start to go like i'm astral
gender like meaning like from space and
and then she just wrapped the segment up
and she was like all right and like
she just walked off and then the club
guy was like
what happened i go i don't know here's
the thing but she called she called
the car so we're leaving and she was
like i hear her talking the guy she's
like
what was that he is weird and i'm
sitting there in the car just like
i'm ear to ear i'm like that was the
most fun i've ever had so doing morning
radio or if
anyone ever accuses you of being phobic
you have to go in 2015
i was leading the charge i was one of
the first numbers setting an example and
i was hate crimed yeah i was she abused
me
i actually was non-binary but i i
i gave it up yeah because i was so hurt
now people will be like oh that's
but this was you know like six years ago
yeah yeah and also
oh and then i have to tell you about the
thing i outed myself for cancer-wise
um i used to once i realized you could
fuck around on morning shows
and is
number one i would wear the clothes from
the plane the night before
because i was like i'm not changing for
this and it started to be so much
funnier to just come from the airport
with no bra on
and like um like jammies and then
uh i would just go through the news
anchors makeup bags because they're
always so
fucking ratchet yeah like they have to
do their own makeup they wear makeups
why dude they have a bag of makeup with
like a brush just in the bag loose and
like a sponge loose
and they have like no looks like someone
fucking face planted them and they don't
get they
are treated like shit yeah they don't
have they have toilet paper that they're
blowing their nose up like
behind the desk made me go i can never
be mad at any of you because this is the
least glamorous job
and y'all are treated like fucking shit
they're doing their own makeup they're
lining no one's powdering them they've
just got the most
fucking germ-infested set up yeah a lot
of them don't people don't realize that
those
you see someone on tv and you had
television but local
they i don't they don't get treated very
well they get treated
terribly when we're like oh there's a
local weather girl she's off on the side
doing her own makeup
doing her own thing running her own
instagram yeah it's like
you know but um but so what i did i
think it was two weeks ago i didn't
remember who the guest was but
i talked about how when i was 20
i was either 18 or 20. i can't remember
because i can't remember i was the end
of college at the end of
uh high school but i i think i i'm in
if i were to not penn state not where
the rape was
it had to be when i was 20. i'm not
going to make myself younger to
have known better i was definitely 20
because i was in la and i had a
two there's two other friends in the
photo that i wouldn't have had sooner
and
i had just seen miss saigon on broadway
i had just read
memoirs of a geisha the book i dressed
as a in a kimono
with white face oh yeah yeah my friend
was charlie chaplin she put white on her
face to look whiter photos out there
a hitler mustache chaplin's musta
we had this theory where like looking
back at it i was like wait a second
was hitler so successful because he had
the charlie chaplin mustache never was
like he's just a fun guy
do you think he calculated that mustache
mustaches you know how why that mustache
was popular then it was very popular
because everyone was on uh
methamphetamines no it's from gas masks
so um gas masks in world war one
couldn't cover your couldn't close here
if your mustache
grew out here so they shaved this so
your gas mask could cover your face
so that mustache became in fashion
because all those men
were in the army and they would cover
their mouth like this
fascinating yeah and then that became if
you if you actually like
we call it a hitler mustache yeah for
obviously i mean he did the most with it
yeah yeah yeah
but it was it was very fashionable in
that period do you know and also your
scar which is so fucking awesome
from your surgery recently uh uh they
used to
just randomly stab to create scars
on nazis faces so that they looked
scarier like the higher and the rank you
got
really brilliant rogan told me this on a
yeah we did
an episode once and he was like telling
me all this crazy stuff about nazis
about how they
were on methamphetamines and all these
crazy drugs nazi
scarring get ready
the badge of honor many nazi officers
yeah officers are there they were part
of the original fight club an
underground fighting gang from the 1800s
and early 1900s so
see they would put scars on their face
they on purpose holy shit
that's like a fucking real scar too it's
like the one on your and as soon as i
saw that one
um uh and they did it on purpose so that
you would know who was
the highest ranking so a higher up would
have a real crazy scar because also yes
you think back of like how did people
control
mobs of people how did they do it like
having a scar on your face definitely
helps people be like don't fuck with
that guy
how were they able to control so many
without the fucking internet
they just were like on a thing going
everybody behave and they're like why
did people fucking behave
oh yeah and you'd see the crowds like
the thousands and thousands they didn't
have the internet they didn't have any
way to communicate
going like that guy on the right is
acting crazy they all just fucking
behaved
they were poor and whatever brainwashed
but um but yeah so
it's called uh oh look at that look at
these scars they would
put to look to look like a badass to
look scarier yeah which is so crazy
that is good and it's effective i want
to talk about this manuscript
is this the book or is it the book yeah
yeah yeah so what
i had literally i went to new york to
write my book because i couldn't
i need i need a week off and i don't
have
anything else also you can go no phone
in the room
egg timer computer with no wi-fi on it
that's a good one i am not leaving
in uh for the until do not do it by page
count i did that for a while
maybe your brain works differently it
will work i would do like i'm not
leaving until i've written 20 pages
uh but then you're writing shitty just
to write longer
faster egg timer
you can get up every 50 minutes for 10
minute break and check your phone and
pee
and get a snack come back but i did an
egg timer
for four hours every morning no and i
i actually wanted to go uh to new york
so i was ahead
of the time frame of the time zone so
people from l.a don't start bothering
you till noon interesting so
you know what i mean i like the change
of location
and new york whether does this reverend
or not it makes me so fucking pissed off
that everyone looks so busy yeah even
though they're not they're just
rushing even when they're not in a rush
i don't even know where everyone's
racing but um
but i'm always like everyone's ahead of
me i got to work harder like it's like a
my competitive brain you know
i pick up that manic energy yeah yeah i
get that i mean new york does something
to me too
like i i i feel like um
i don't know i kind of feel like i
thrive in a way there um
as long as it's like a kind of condensed
period of time
also something that works for me is to
give myself an incentive
that punishes me so if i don't work for
two hours this week
i don't know who told me this trick or
where i heard it but
you write a check for 300
to donate to like rush limbaugh he's
dead but
someone that you agree disagree with
horribly and then if you don't finish it
you have to send that check
to the person so like some kind of
punishment
or this is 500 if i don't get this done
i'm giving this to the una bomber yes
mail it to someone superman mail it to
like uh the menendez brothers in prison
like something
they deserve a break something that
it'll
just enough money to make a shank out of
a jolly rancher yeah so it's like i
think that our brains need that kind of
punishment like
a mine does or you can go stay in a
hotel that's expensive
and go i'm going to be here to if i
don't use to justify this if
now i have to justify that it's like
when you go on vacation and you start
fucking
even if you don't want to just like
we're gonna fucking earn this room this
room is a thousand dollars
we better fuck all the yeah yeah the
whole time yeah
but you have a really good vacation do
you ever feel pressured to have sex on a
vacation
even if you don't want to uh yeah
because it is part of his like we're in
this beautiful place
and we've been here already six hours
we've been fucked
yeah yeah you have to it's like such a
like
like this is now we're putting pressure
on our personal lives when we're on
vacation now that we're
we're treating fucking like work now
that we're not working
i get so excited about planning a
vacation that i can turn a vacation into
like
like an event i put on instead of like
chilling
yeah vacation has become my one year
zella i am i'm bridezilla for vacations
yeah i
i have we were gonna go see the the
whales right where we were going whale
watching i wanted to be like all a
certain way and
today we were gonna do the massage yeah
you're you over stress yourself trying
to relax
yeah yeah and i try to get let myself or
tell myself not to get like worked up
about shit that
you know didn't go the way i wanted it
to being flexible on vacation
but you're also a leader by nature and a
businessman by nature and it's sort of
like i want to get the most out of it i
want the service to be amazing
you know we never get to vacation though
so when we do we put too much pressure
on it yeah i do
that's the truth because it's like the
vacation's like one week in the
mid it's not like oh it's summer let's
go it's like it's always a what random
week
yeah that i have off between things you
know so i want to ask if you get to
vacation i want to ask about
going from being a comedian to a
boss of many many people and producer of
things is not talking about acting we
have to still talk about how hot i am
and blake and how hot you are i was
watching uh
your mom's house from i think like a
week ago maybe it was like a week ago
episode i can't remember
and i was like i you look
i've always thought you were hot i have
to say this and sexually harass you
because it's our turn
and to make you uncomfortable thank you
and also
i i'm over this whole thing where guys
like are like well i'm just schlubby and
i'm just this and i'm like dude it's the
hottest thing ever
i'm schlubby yes i get it but why why do
we keep like i'm just curious why we
keep
saying that like i had um you know what
i mean
yeah cause people talk about how hot you
are and i'm gonna say it oh really they
talk about it
oh really yes i've yet to hear these
comments i know
i'm here because comedians we talk shit
yeah to each other's faces and nice
behind our backs
that is so true that is so true
and um yeah we should every once in a
while be nicer to each other
why are we because here's the other
thing because we're just insecure
like sensitive kids still we're all just
you know and like in high school or
middle school that's just how you are
you know like when bert and i did your
show when you're out we it was so
fucking brutal you guys mean to each
other oh the comments were like
whitney should bird should like sue him
it was so rough
like it was so i was because i came on
and i thought i was i was trying to make
your audience laugh and i was like
trying to be funny they they want you to
be there
and i can't i'm not you well you know
yeah and i'm just trying to go savage on
jokes and jokes and jokes because i
think oh this audience likes like rough
jokes i'm gonna go for it
burt and i it was so fucking brutal and
then we get off and we're in the parking
lot we're like dude i love you i just
don't know what i would do without you
and thank god that
are you more sentimental now though like
you know the older you get
like i i am way more and i'm i also will
like like i will just like tell people
the good things i think about them just
randomly you know i mean like i'll do it
and i'll fucking sometimes weep about it
i mean i don't know it's just as you get
old i think to me it's like i never kind
of thought
to do that because i always thought my
vulnerability would be used against me
and i always thought especially if i was
beneath someone
i was sucking up to them sure people
would think i was trying to kiss
someone's ass or like
you know i think comedians i think it
might appear weak to to do that or like
like you're trying to be i don't know
submissive or something but that's not
really where it's coming from for me you
know and i don't want to give you power
or like be punctuous and like be
you know there's a there's a point where
people are so fake that when someone's
sincere people think it's fake
that's so true so if i'm just like dude
i love you dude you're so awesome like
my like um authentically direct people
i sometimes and people like you when i
just say dude i love you so much you're
so cool people why are you being
sarcastic
i'm like dude you think i'm sarcastic
because most people are so saccharine
and fake
yeah that means just being straight
seems mean
it feels good to actually like i think
people realize that you're actually
you think that when the person tells you
you know i think you're awesome and i
love you
you think that it's it's for the person
you're telling it's for the person
that's saying it
interesting you know like that it feel
for me it feels good to get that out
that i think this about you and i i want
to tell you
but also this you know because of
whatever it was our childhoods our
programming our
trauma our being bullied whatever it was
you know
you commenting on my page with topher
grace hey asshole yeah yeah it's funny
that's
that's like we're friends that's love
that's fun that's what we do
yes but a lot of other people are like
what the fuck and you're like
you don't get to do it that's what we do
yes it's like those people don't know
how to bust balls
a lot of times you know we can bust bus
balls as comics and then
you know you walk out after a show and
someone's like hey fuck head and you're
like
what's up and they're like hey nice
fucking show you idiot and you're like
what are you doing they're like i'm just
fucking
idiot you're the one that paid 80
dollars yeah like what are you talking
about and also like
this is how you meet people do you feel
weird security stuff sometimes
sometimes yeah do you have a gun
um i've had to like you know i've had
weird threats before
so i've had to like when do you know
when do you i always talk about the book
the gift of fear on this podcast
um of when your gut tells you this
is this is feels real and this because
they always say threats are actually the
ones that aren't gonna be carried out
for the most part
yeah like if someone's gonna kill you
they're not gonna give you a heads up
that's probably true
there's been a couple things where i
think it's your instinct you're just
you're interested
yeah and then i've like sent the um
you know the perceived threat to like a
a company that deals with that
then they give me like
you know if i needed the money i would
um i just had like
i sent it to like a company that deals
with that and then they give you like a
risk assessment thing
like a background check and the whole
thing and then you kind of decide yeah
like and then once you realize how
expensive it is to look into it you're
like
i'll take the rest i'm i'm strong
i'll be able to handle i'll be okay
between me and christina
and our injuries we're perfectly able to
defend ourselves yeah i i
i need a hand of defending myself are
you uh i know i have to let you go soon
um i want i want to so that we i don't
want to ruin our friendship
um uh but how is the austin change are
you talking about it
on your podcast how do you feel when did
you really go
i remember talking to you guys you were
like we're gonna we might i'll tell you
this
with any and i think most guys would go
along with this you have a a
change a move something like that
planned when your
wife get becomes the the like driving
force
and it's like we're doing this you
realize oh this is really happening so
for me
i used to do this thing that put her
over the edge well i used i used to
all the time how did you get her to
leave a fancy
palisades house this is what happened i
i i don't believe you didn't strong
armor
i i did i swear with a nerf gun and
you're interrupting so much that you
didn't notice
i shot you with the nerf gun i uh when i
interrupt she shoots me with a nerf gun
it's all good
i used to what if he's being boring
that's true can you shoot him with a
nerf gun
i'm being i could be i'm joking i um i
used to have this infatuation with
denver i still do i love denver
and so i used to come sometimes i would
do a weekend or something to come home
i'd be like what do you think think
about moving to denver
and you know she would go i mean yeah
it's cool but like you know we're not
i'm not leaving like i'm an angelino i'm
never leaving
and i was like okay and i would just be
like a fantasy and then
last year i think you know the pandemic
we were talking about affects people in
different ways
it there was like there was this time
where it felt like
like la is felt like it's falling apart
and which by the way was never together
that's my argument yeah i believe
everyone's like ellie's gone to shit
it was always always kind of crazy what
are we doing
then the combination of things of like
having a crazy year
having issues with like schools we have
two little kids that will be going into
school
um touring being like this thing where
like it exhausts you
from the south what west pocket of
everything is a five and six hour flight
and entertaining the idea today it's
like you're in the middle of the country
um going to austin seeing like what it's
like you know
going about seeing the homes in the
school and what you can get for your
money
what you can get for your money and like
it being a super business friendly state
and like having our company grow
it's like you weighed all those factors
then we actually went and looked
you know started looking going making
trips to look at houses
even then i was still like yeah and then
when she became the louder voice
she was like oh you know this park and
this school and this thing and like this
is where
so i i kind of was like yeah we're going
through the motions
and then her becoming the louder voice
and it made me go like and her mama bear
instincts going this is where i want my
kids
yeah and then like you know you go like
yeah i kind of think this is cool then
her being like we're doing this and then
i remember going if we don't like it
we'll just move back you know what you
there's no rule against that's not a
hassle and she was like there's no
fucking way we're moving back
and i was like oh okay like that's when
i realized like oh she's
dead on serious about this and then she
took the lead
i don't think she knew she was going to
fall down around stairs in a new house
so maybe we'll
maybe we'll pivot maybe
to marching fucked his house it's not a
word we use anymore oh shit
uh but she uh
oh fuck it's such a that's six months by
the way in six months
i have been severely injured i haven't
been asking because i don't want you to
have to answer questions a billion times
that's totally fine but it's just crazy
that it's six like in a six-month window
now she and then
i'm getting another operation next month
on your arm
i want to apologize to you for what um
good point i've done nothing wrong
uh no annie and i made a video making
fun of your fault
and we felt like it was too soon once we
but once we we were like
this is too soon oh it's fine i was like
we shouldn't post this but
she actually fell and it looked so real
yeah no i think i remember seeing it i i
wasn't bothered by it and then i was
like ah
i feel like it might be too far in that
time i had like
a thousand memes videos yeah people deep
fake things they put me like in space
flying around
like i mean to me it was like just
another thing
you know i don't i still don't think
i've watched the video because i
truly just can't it's pretty it's gnarly
i've seen it so many times
it's gnarly dude and it like people
don't understand that like
if it changes that's an injury that
changes your body forever
yeah like i don't when i shattered my
shoulder
snowboarding because i'm young and cool
and
it was a um lateral uh
fracture so it was like the entire and
then a rotator cuff thing
i had to do physical therapy three hours
a day for eight months
like literally holding a pencil
yeah just doing this yeah yeah i've done
all this
literally this for 30 minutes you're
just like i'm going to blow my brains
out
people don't understand that the next
year of your life is just oh yeah i'm
only six months out i mean was your
surgeon here are you getting the next
surgery here
here the same person's going to do
everyone different guy no no so
i got i had a trauma surgeon here do my
these two surgeries
and then i have a nerve specialist doing
this other surgery
she got injured in austin which was a
dream
because you go to a top five hospital in
a much
smaller even though it's a big it's a
city it's a smaller city
i'm doing it here because my injury
occurred here and i have
a system of doctors i've worked
yesterday you can't fucking say i don't
know
i don't want to switch i want to stay i
want to stay with the same people good
so where are you going to stay when you
come do that that's
interesting my house might be done
really yes i i
am i've been entertaining where to stay
because for that trip like i like
checking out different hotels but for
that trip i'm like i think i should stay
someplace that like i really feel safe
you know also have
like a friend with you like it's not a
game like you're after
emily knows this because i secretly
tried to get when she was my assistant
breast implants and not tell her yeah
but i couldn't lift anything that was
over five pounds and i i'm not allowed
to pick up anything with this by the way
i had the surgery
and i would just be like can you pick up
that coffee for me i was just became an
asshole so i was like i had a surgery
like i had to eventually tell her
because i'm like can you carry my purse
and not telling her why
you're gonna have to have someone i'm
gonna have to have someone
uh so when in this one they're gonna cut
me open full misery
full misery you're gonna keep me yes
just keep injuring you
dude it wouldn't take much produce my
podcast that's right you got it
this thing is gonna be you can't lift
anything more than so at first i have
two weeks i don't pick anything up
like just don't touch anything because
it can't turn off
your right hand yeah and i usually do
like a cup and release i'm pretty good
um some guys like to do it with their
own i gotta tell you they're bad hands
so it sound
feels like someone that's never done it
before i want to say i don't know if
i've i think i could work a dick like i
think
i really think i could give a great hand
job i think i could honestly give a
pretty spectacular blowjob
but can i tell you something a bit that
i'm working on that i'm never going to
be able to do
okay and i might even have to cut out
i'm not going to cut this out i'm going
to say it
i was working on a bit that part of the
reason ever been so afraid of trans
women is because they know how to use a
dick
and they will replace cis women because
once a man gets a blowjob or hand job
from someone that knows how a dick works
they'll never go back to me never
so right i know someone famous he's kind
of famous so i can't say what it is
uh one day basically was like
in all these relationships and every
time he would have sex with someone it
would get sticky and
crazy and was like i just want me to
accept and was like i'm not gonna get a
prostitute because they're gonna
snitch i'm gonna feel bad i'm gonna feel
like basically felt too bad for his
sexual needs he goes you know what i'm
just gonna get
i'm gonna do the back of l.a weekly
remember when they had all those sex and
i'm gonna have a guy come suck my dick
because they won't i won't fall in love
with them i won't feel bad
comes gets his dicks like my man has
never gone back
he's gay now not not gay just gets his
dick
sucked and hand-jobbed by a man and
still dates women really
for two decades or something like i'm
pretty sure he's gay now
but no basically he's like once you have
he's like i did not realize
what was possible because women we don't
know how much spirit we don't
no one no woman gives a good hand job
i'm sorry if you're listening don't be
mad at me
but there's no way even if you're really
good at giving it to your boyfriend now
the next guy's dick seems to be totally
different so you got to relearn it every
time we learn what he likes and how
like that and i'm into teeth and no
teeth and is there much spit and now
it's circumcised i didn't know i don't
know how to do that now i have to
fucking
do a french braid like i don't even know
what this is you know so it's everyone
is so different so
start with his bag ladies start with his
bag really
yeah but also buttholes are now in play
really in play and i've been trying to
get that action it's just not happening
but
she's just not into it not happening a
finger
or a licky lick i would love a licula
are you kidding me dude how do you know
that it's good
you've had it before no i've never had a
lick
i i i've i've just heard great stories
and i've watched videos like who
okay you've watched videos of porn stars
that pretend something feels yeah yeah
yeah but i also talked to
and you've heard stories real people
from our mentally ill friends
that get it from prostitutes some of
them who had horrible childhoods
and have fucked up kinks because of it
don't ruin my dreams
i'm trying to make you happier with your
marriage no it's good
i'm trying to make you not cave and get
a hooker at two in the morning and
pensacola
yeah um but yeah i feel like the ass
eating thing is a little bit like it if
a guy doesn't i'm like is this for you
or for me
i don't like you you don't get a thrill
i don't it's not for me
okay that's fair i get the butt plug
thing you do like
i get it because my thing is even if i'm
not feeling
something's not like getting me off
right away if it gets someone
else off so much i'm like great that's
i'm into that
yeah if you're so if you're so into it
there's something hot to me about that
yeah you know
when we go to nordstrom you have to hold
my purse you don't want to but it makes
me so happy then i'll do it you'll do it
sure you know what i mean so it's like
i'll take one for the team
i don't have to understand why you're
into it yeah but yeah uh who was
last week on the podcast we did uh
benton explained that the g spot for men
which i knew in the butt
you know but i don't know how to do that
to a guy
you could figure it out no i couldn't
what if you just go through like my
guy's butt he's a rock climber and his
butt is like the end of a sausage with
the little
iron little piece of metal i can't get
in there you push on his taint though
i try to but i don't think he really on
the outside
uh no i try but his butt's too tight
too tight i can't get in there he's a
rock climber give him a minute with me
let's be honest i don't try that hard i
give i'm pretty i it takes him very
little
to is he asking for something to give up
no no there you go
no but younger guys he's younger and
he's 30 i'm it 38.
up um but yeah i know isn't it weird
it was a pandemic like joke relationship
that was based on
him liking you how did you guys meet he
saved my dog's life
this is really how you met yes and where
was the dog he had to be hospitalized my
dog
frank and i begged them to let me stay
in the hospital
uh cage with him and sleep with him
overnight which is totally against the
rules but i think they were like this
woman is so unstable we have to just let
her or
she won't stop crying in the lobby um
and so i was in the crate with him i had
like a
a beanie on and then when i left i
wanted to leave something with him so he
could smell me in the crate
um i don't have children um and
i put it on his head and then you know
when there's like a picture on your
dog's profile they took a picture of him
with the beanie on and he just looks so
cute
and alex does he does critical care so
he would never deal with that yet
but critical care vet mm-hmm okay so
that's perfect for you
dude how dumb oh my god so basically
it's so stupid and literally i was like
i can't date a critical verb
that's a little on the nose like
everyone already knows i know but i was
like this is like hacky and he just
comes home and tells you what he did
that day and you just weep every day
well he has to put a lot of dogs down
but he can do an iv drip when i'm
hungover um and so
i he saw it and he was like oh that
dog's cute and then was like oh that's
whitney cummings dog
and then saw all the things and was just
like let me
and then he was the next person to come
out i'd never met him before all of a
sudden this like 30 year old like
hawkeye comes out with a little like
butt switching and his little scrubs and
my i'm friends with dan levy from shit's
creek
and you've seen that show yes i've seen
the show and you know there's a fucking
hot vet
and then a holly like a alexis okay i
haven't seen much of the show so okay
i know the show i know the show i'm just
a liar okay
i know i just want this story to fucking
end what do i have to say to you no no i
i know the show it's about a hot it's
like a hot vet and a girl who's kind of
so
we are like ted and alexis basically for
people that have seen the show but he
comes out and i was like always giving
dan shit going
why did you cast such a hot vet i'm at
vets every day they do not look like
this like giving him shit about it
and then fucking alex walks out and he's
so handsome
and i was like oh fuck and i saw i saw
his cute little ass on your instagram i
know you're talking about it
then i can't get my finger in i know
it's so tight and then
i look at him and he's giving me
information about my dying dog trying to
help me
and i'm such a fucking asshole that i
was like i'm going to take a photo of
him while he's talking so i can say
that's a dance because i want to send
him to dance because he's talking you're
like
i want to know i was secretly doing it
and uh
i was trying to send it to dan to go oh
my god you're right there are hot bats
right i need so badly to like fucking
finish an argument that i wasn't
listening and i wanted so bad to make
him laugh
so i'm like trying to take a picture of
him he's giving me all this important
information
and then he was just like are you taking
a photo
and i was like no and then it was like
right here and i was like i'm
recording it so that i can listen to it
later he's like well that's illegal and
i was like
got it so i put the phone away and he's
talking and i'm like all i'm doing is
like i gotta get this photo and then he
walks away
and then i'm like i have to video his
butt and then he turns around and it's
like
what are you doing like it was like so
bad it was so
fucking bad fucking researching bro and
then we were texting because he was like
just text me directly
so that i can help you and then he
texted me about your special at midnight
he had a couple whiskeys and was like
i'm gonna text this
fucking i feel pretty like i feel pretty
special about that i know it's a red
flag that he's into your comedy but i
saw
him anyway i saw him anyway the fact
that you followed up after somebody said
that it's a major relationship
and then he i'm like didn't his special
suggest
like have you not seen my um and thank
god he hadn't
and then the pandemic happened and i had
a dog fight
and a dog shook a little dog and their
eyeballs came out
and i had to drive it to the vet and
remember at the beginning of the
pandemic when we were wiping down
groceries yes remember when
we so i didn't have a mask i was sobbing
crying
i tried to get to the vet the doors
closed they won't let me in because i'm
the pandemic is just starting
nowhere and i'm like i'm just spinning
droplets yeah
and then he came out and helped and
helped and then came over to my house
and that's is that when you started yes
and then i would
say no okay later i started day drinking
when i thought my career was over
forever
did you think at a point like we're
never doing stand-up again um
so what i remember was i i had it was
march is when things shut down i had a
march
some march shows we moved to april right
they're like we're moving them to april
and then in april i was like do you
think we're gonna move these to may and
they're like i think so
so that happened again and then we were
like um these aren't happening for a
while
and i did go i didn't know if i'd rather
do standup again but i was like
thank first i was like thank god i have
podcasting cause i was like what you
know by the way you were the smartest
person in the world as soon as that
pandemic came i was like god
damn it with the live shows with not
only that
but um having all your podcast umbrella
your numerous podcasts that could be
shot
you would you i was like segura is the
most secure person in hollywood right
now
and then you started figuring out the
live ones the live ones were game
changers game changers
do you ever worry that doing the live
shows if they come to live show like
what if they don't go
come to the when you do stand up well
the live shows that we did were
so different yeah it's just a ticketed
event so in a cheap ticket it was just
based on we're trying to do mass volume
so we made 10
tickets crazy so like you know 10 you're
not price gouging someone for ten
dollars yeah
but you want to do massive volume and we
just didn't know
what the market would be for it and then
we did it and we were like holy shit
crazy so and then it was just about like
your logan paul boxing all the sudden
yeah exactly and then but you know
they're doing like fucking 50
pay-per-views but
they try even you know people tried to
get us to raise the price like you know
product you know agents and everything
and i was like no no keep it there it's
such a big difference there's a reason
every
uh price tag says something 99 1999
you see the 19 it's it's the same as 20
but 20 is psychologically ecologically
yeah
so we wanted to keep it like that and
then all my only thing is i
we only do them if i feel like
there's value in that ticket meaning
like we can shoot extra
sketches like we are love making sketch
and like emily and um sigoura did a
sketch together that i did not authorize
i'm gonna send a cease and desist yeah
yeah i don't know if i could show it to
you but
it was um like when so we shoot that
stuff to make the ticket like so you're
not like i'm just watching them do their
regular podcast
so shoot extra content shoot things or
show things that
you can't show on youtube so uncensored
things and we just kind of tried to
make it a destination event event yes
and so are you ever gonna do only fans
no i you know it's funny that i try to
you should put your surgeries on only
pants
dude dude your neck surgery you should
put on only there's one next month maybe
i should set everything up i'm not i'm
not i didn't realize like when
people asked you know talk to me about
only fans and i was like only fans and
then they showed me that like
fat joe and dj co i'm like they're on
only fans but they're just like hanging
out and doing
chelsea lynn is fucking killing on there
like because there's
makes me so happy because and it's not
like i can't show my tits we're comics
you know that i've had this idea i
talked about it with i can't remember
who on the podcast
but i wanted to do a only fans that
instead of dirty photos and videos was
like dirty jokes like that we're not
allowed to tell anymore oh yeah and do
like a real roast
yeah with like me you and bert and we're
saying
we're doing what used to be the comedy
central roast yeah jeff ross and
everybody
you miss rose i don't miss them
as much now because i learned that
you kill the hardest when you're kind of
a newcomer yeah that's the best pocket
to be in
and as you look back and you're like
that's who was always like i got to say
joan rivers i loved you and the wrestler
yeah you know what i mean like i got to
say stuff like who's that bitch
and then people don't really they just
like they had such low expectations for
me
right right that i came out and that
kind of bravery was so shocking
once you're established and i was like i
got nothing to fucking lose yeah
now when i would write rose jokes i'm
like ah this i don't want my employees
to get cancelled if i do this joke
like i just have too much to lose now so
i don't feel as brave
and then i also think that roasts
stopped being as fun and funny
when twitter became a roast it used to
be like
one night a year you get to hear crazy
shit and you tried to get me a roast job
do you remember that
you probably remember that sounds like
you called me i mean this is years ago
yeah and i was like
what's up and you're like hey man you
should submit a packet for this thing
and i was like really and you're like
yeah i'm going to connect you to this
person tell me they're abusing me
no you're like send in a packet right
write some jokes for this
so i did i didn't get the job we should
read those on something
on your only if you should have gotten
one you're only fantastic dude if i were
to go through the roasters that i've
written that never
like flavor flavor you look like what
magic johnson should look like right now
some more did that joke yeah but that
was like one of in my initial packet
like if we're able to say it's a killer
joke though
it's why they hired me because they
needed to use that joke and then i got
hired for a week and they were gonna let
me go
and then i knew i had to fucking earn
money i'm writing some fucking haymakers
man
savage yeah where am i going with that
oh and then i remember i was on the red
carpet
and we would have to you have to make
jokes about whatever you can yeah so
when sarah silverman got destroyed for
being like old it was like
it like she went on a podcast about it
like it was like she didn't it was awful
you know but also it was like wait a
second why i'm not old
and i'm hot everyone's like i used to
jerk off to you when i was 10. i was
like you still jerk off to her yeah yeah
you know she by the way
has anyone aged better in all of
entertainment she's one of the most
beautiful people i've ever seen she
looks like a doll
i mean i saw sarah like at the store i
don't know
whatever it was six eight months
whatever it was however many months ago
and i was like
she looks exactly exactly like you look
like 20 years ago shocking
she probably because she's not baby
blood it's fucking she's gargling with
baby boy baby blood but also she's um
probably she doesn't go to the community
till 20 mo the morning like i've done
for the past 15 years
you know i mean she's also doesn't do
the road is hard she's got to be yeah
she's very interested she goes on she
takes she um
she's wise when she's wise when she did
her tv show i remember her uh
saying that she'll do three weeks on and
then take a week off i'm gonna age 15.
she won't allow
the fucking schedules that we murder
ourselves on she's like no i need to
sleep
yeah she's like she has self-respect i
have to pee
it's summer i'm hot i need a bowl of
magic spoon
i know most people would want ice cream
iced tea
froyo not here and good for you
here we enjoy a summer bowl of magic
spoon
i think by the way i mean if you guys
just read it once before
i read it you'll see there's so many
typos oh yeah i wrote it at night
um also i'm dyslexic so you get what you
get
hello there
[Music]
it's magic
how does the good for you team enjoy a
treat that's zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs per serving
that's only 140 calories per serving
that's keto friendly gluten-free
grain-free soy-free low-carb and gmo
free
lots of different ways
one more time for the people in the back
the high protein keto friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free
wheat-free naturally flavored totally
delicious childlike cereal for grown-ups
[Music]
i'm gonna get this
and the emmy for best sound editing goes
too
high my magic
i am blown away i am will be blown away
if anyone can hear anything we said
during that ad
build your own box available flavors to
build your very own custom bundle are
cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
and cinnamon
go to magicspoon.com whitney to grab a
custom bundle of cereal
and try it today and be sure to use our
promo code whitney
at checkout to save five dollars on your
order and magic spoon is also so
confident in their product
that it's backed with a 100 percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com whitney and use the
code whitney to save
five dollars off did you see any guilt
in that video
um i have some free writing
it's guilt the same as uh remorse his
guilt the same as
regret yeah yeah i only feel shame so i
don't know
taking another break in our hilarious
conversation with tom to talk about how
much we enjoy
taking breaks lounging on our article
furniture in fact no one works harder or
deserves
more lounge time than our then it should
be
physically it emotionally challenged
emily noonan and now we're gonna watch
benton's directorial debut why because
it's
i'm starring it is features article
furniture because honestly
words words can't do justice to how much
we love article furniture we love it
we've said it you guys probably don't
believe us right now you probably think
we're exaggerating being anxious but
emily's about to show you
there's no exaggeration actions speak
louder than words so watch me sit
before i had articles i used to have to
lounge like this
it's a wheelbarrow not good
but now i can lounge like this ashley
yes sorry when you say actual i love my
article lounger
i can't do this i'm sorry mention i
can't do this emily you can do it just
what tell us about article
article combines the curation of
boutique furniture store with the
comfort and simplicity of shopping
online
add to cart but we didn't even do the
line
i think we got it no article furniture
you can
have it delivered right to your door
beautiful furniture that beautifies
every space
any space all right let's try this again
okay
i love article furniture they bring
custom
they bring custom furniture right to
your door right to your door
it's fast affordable and offers free
shipping for orders over 999
like this amazing lounger this is a
nightmare
i don't get it i just don't understand
what we're doing with this this is a
waste of time you have to tell them
about article is article even going to
like this i love who are doing these ads
but i don't understand the point of this
why would i put
why would i put this piece of furniture
here i can't but i need you to i can't
be this unprepared
i don't understand if i'm supposed to
let people know that article
i love my article lounger i take it with
me everywhere
i must put a giant mint in my mouth
article furniture is so convenient even
a woman can move it
why am i saying that why am i saying
that where am i moving
i just stepped in dog shit don't wait
for your construction to be over
beautify it now no don't tell me
look how seamlessly this beautiful
lounger spices up this active
construction zone
ah okay
need a hard hat but i'm still
comfortable
can i get a drink
article for active lounging
immediately delivered didn't leave me
hanging
it really is a beautiful chair if that
doesn't sell you i don't know what will
uh also i just um it
you know it's a great it's a great
furniture to have a complete
nervous breakdown on i mean we just
watched a um
like a manic break happened those jump
cuts were just literally emily
it was just me taking out everything all
of emily's breakdowns we saw emily uh
have a nervous breakdown on article
furniture but you know it won't break
the article furniture bam comfortable
breakdown should have
been she had a very glamorous breakdown
inspired by a variety of modern design
aesthetics
like mid-century scandinavian industrial
and bohemian fair prices you save up to
over traditional retail prices article
is able to keep their prices low
by cutting the shit they cut out the
middleman
and they sell directly to you no
showrooms no sales people
no retail markups no salespeople what do
we call emily
i come with the chair article is
offering our listeners 50 off your first
purchase of 100
or more go to article.com whitney and
the discount will be automatically
applied at
checkout that's article.com whitney to
get 50
dual errors off your first purchase of
100 or
more emily do you want to sit in and
respond as tom
oh yeah and then we'll have just i got a
lot to say
um emily is wearing a baby doll dress
today
to spite me i meant to come in today and
say i'm not taking feedback on my
clothes
i have plans tonight what are you doing
tonight i have a prairie hoedown
i'm going to say are you going to be
sold off by your father yep
i'm going to have my first blood where
did you get this dress
did you get it i i warned you about this
dress
um did you get it at the antique road
show did you take it off of a doll
a haunted doll are you i knew you was
gonna say this
dead body did you she was this is their
nightgown she was a civil war baby
i'm so thrilled i fit in it
my mom got this for me for my birthday
okay because i'm her special little baby
so she's not enabling at all
this is good this is like a milkshake
yeah it's like a hazelnuts
like it's a smoothie just a coffee
disguises this one is it whole30
no what is whole30 i love that your
outfits
and your diets are the same age whole30
was like before the south beach diet as
a diet fad
yes and i'm i get there it's always five
years later right right okay got it and
how's your whole 30 going
well it hasn't started yet because i
just drank this what is it it's when you
like uh it's a book
it's a it's a it's a lifestyle change
you know about what the diet requires
have you read this book that you're
telling everyone no you're doing it i'm
carrying it around it's in my purse
okay so it is carrying around is that
what burns the calories to make it hold
30. it's making me give me a little arm
strength
does it uh require exercise no
what can you i can't exercise i'm a baby
emily
emily on the emily on a diet is just
eating something and halfway through
going is this good for my diet is this
total 30 you'll just eat something go is
this whole 30 after you've already eaten
it
yeah emily's on the whole 30. uh tom
here comes my tv boyfriend uh where is
the sketch
that you're in it's on pay-per-view
it's on my only fan tell me about the
tour how did you pick the cities you
picked
something kind of fascinating that i
would like to say to everyone listening
is that there's two reasons we're all
going to the most random cities
number one there have been no venues
available yeah because of the fucking
smash and grab of everyone rushing to
try to get venues after the pandemic
yeah if you fucking didn't respond to a
text from your agent in 30 seconds and
you were at the fifth hold
you lost it to a youtube star yeah so
now venues are not just comedy and music
tic toc stars are showing powerpoint
presentations
you're gonna shit when i tell you what
i've signed up for you look pissed
i've seen your tour schedule and it's
not happening well let me tell you
something do you want to just cancel
them now
how's what about did you hear what i
just said did christina
22 cancel the first leg of her tour
let me ask you something so i looked at
this and i was like so maybe he's done
podcasting
me you're like does he have it i don't
know i just i don't i look at your tour
schedule and i'm like oh
he wants to get a divorce like there's
easier ways to get a divorce
it's dude it's uh i'm coming everywhere
okay click here for info tickets so
oh you're doing some some uh one small
uh date in ontario to kind of just work
shit out that's a spanish show i'm doing
a show in spain okay i'm so obsessed
with you doing these spanish shows
yeah yeah i watched the one of the
espanol ones with uh
joey diaz oh yeah yeah is it is this
something that's just like
something i wanted to do and then i
didn't realize it was going to become a
thing
and then they were like you can do a
special in spanish and like i was like
oh that's kind of interesting and then
now i'm working at it and it takes so
much more work but is the special in
spanish the special you do in english
translating or is it kind of different
material it started as that because i
was going to shoot it
a year ago which i was totally not ready
for but i was just doing that material
as
time has gone on it's evolved and turned
into
some material just written for it like
in other words
written in spanish for a
spanish-speaking audience
some bits that are translated from
english to spanish and then figuring out
how to make them work because sometimes
the beats don't work exactly
and the translation i remember you were
at the comedy store once with someone do
you mind using this i've done this stuff
doing the thing that i demand everybody
else fucking do but i can't set an
example
with these coasters and so um
you had someone with you and i was so
fascinated because i was like it's hard
enough to do stand up it's hard enough
to write great jokes it's hard enough to
get up there and ascertain if they're
working or not
i get off stage and i'm like what worked
what didn't then to have someone going
that's not translating or
there's not a word for this in spanish
richard villa has come with me a lot and
he worked
a lot in mexico already like he's toured
there
crazy so he would at the shows he'll do
a lot of the shows with me
he'll i'll also get off stage and be
like yeah that one thing didn't work and
he'll be like yeah but here's why
and he'll give me that fascinating and
i'm like oh here's why it's not funny
it's not funny and you suck you are
shaking
are you ever like did that work because
it didn't translate he's like no but
translated translated
it's just it's not it's a very poor guy
that's the problem about it your
premises are
terrible at least when you speak spanish
poorly they laugh maybe
you keep it a little more robust yeah
it's at least you'll get a joke on
youtube that's a whole
fucking thing man but yeah i'm
continuing to do those you're going to
cities i've never heard of
really yeah like ham in indiana yeah
i've never heard of that either i've
never heard of it never heard of it i've
done
i've been touring it's a casino and a
huge check and i'm doing it okay great
but that's interesting why doesn't yours
say casino okay some of them do i always
get embarrassed when it's a casino oh i
have something i'm like can you change
it to something else they're like
i made them stop saying casino and spa i
was like when does this come out i'm not
putting in spots can i ask you this is
coming
up back out next wednesday next
wednesday okay so july
i'm looking at it 21st uh we announced
the second leg which is february through
june
uh so that's another like fucking i
don't know how many dates yeah
and so we're doing it we're stacked
because you don't want to announce like
hey you wanna buy tickets to the show in
late
20 20 22 whatever it is so we're we're
doing it like
but it's well it's a
it is a daunting skill you need a little
help in hampton beach
yeah hampton beach well you're doing
three shows and
we're doing four now okay so those are
okay i'm just fast oh yes you are one of
them sold out you're right you're right
right
no three are sold out now these maybe
not it's not it's not that drives me
nuts yeah yeah it drives me nuts do you
have to chase around people now
i just tell them to tell the and then
sometimes they don't it drives me insane
yeah and so when people listening this
is actually important it seems boring
but people i have i announced the tour
this week half of the texts are like
it's not on the website it's sold out i
can't buy tickets but you're saying
there are tickets i'm like that's
because no one's updated it yet
i'm fucking sorry no one told me it was
sold out we added a second show added a
second show
there's no link on the website for the
second show you gotta have them all
connected man
to be a comedian now i also have to like
you have to be a
fucking entrepreneur you got a great
shirt on by the way
i think it's fucking disgusting and the
fact that i paid for it is
i'm amazed i would have sent you any
merch you wanted but
that's jeremy fish designed i love this
yeah he did a good job i also love the
colors even though
if you saw the if i saw the colors on
them if i saw the colors on a mock-up i
would think it was ugly
yeah what like how it works you have the
wherewithal to put the
worst colors together and it works all
jeremy fish he's a badass designer you
know who he is
jeremy fish i think jemmy fish does like
he's an artist that does like
he has a lot of like animal stuff in his
designs and he did four
cr like amazing designs for us merch is
so hard
merch is hard how much time do you
dedicate to it
um by the way this is also like james
purse quality
t-shirt yes it doesn't feel like there's
something that would be nice because
shot out of a gun but i did that on
purse because it was his design i was
like we can't throw it on just like a
photo
are you ever like this is gonna i mean i
look at h3hd and gila klein i'm like
well they are like there's stuff you
could find in like neiman marcus i mean
but the teddy fresh stuff
have you ordered have you gotten a
package of it you open it up and it's
like
christmas morning the the the tissues
are great and also like there's a
there's
she's the coolest she's a fucking
fashion designer her taste is
unbelievable
but i'm always like how much did this
cost like it it might come in like a
seven i like it
i know when i stutter on a fucking good
i'm always trying to i want to i always
try to raise the uh
you know the value like whether it's
hiring an awesome designer or getting
better fabrics yeah and then you see
shit like their stuff and you're like oh
well but i think they have a fashion
collection they have a fashion
their stuff is so thick and high quality
and i'm like i to charge that amount of
money i'm like i can't believe this is
actually worth it
because i try not to go over sixty
dollars but theirs is like
you're investing in sleep she'll have
forever like you'll wear it to the club
yeah gym saying we've gotten mine as
you'll wear it to bed yeah
mind the people like i'm gonna paint in
this okay
this is what i wipe my baby's ass with
this is unbelievable
your mariscopa arizona i don't think
i've ever even heard a casino
all the cities you've never heard of our
casinos that's so fucking true yeah yeah
um hawaii you know you made it when you
have fucking
are you doing new year's eve in hawaii
are you chilling yeah yeah yeah
bill maher used to have that gig in
there yeah he's doing it too that's what
it is
yeah he's doing well he's doing a
different he's doing like the day before
or something
richmond i'm going there vegas you're
doing a lot of vegas
the ryman you're doing a bunch of shows
in nashville that's gonna be so fucking
fun god damn it
this is a why don't you have more
dates in texas given that you live there
well i have a remember the whole thing
we were like i'm going to be in the
middle of the country and none of us
never
i have a texas run in january but it
hasn't been announced yet or it's not no
it should be on there
it's uh it's like lubbock yeah midland
san antonio by the way
i love it i love that people like you
that i watched perform at fucking shitty
shows
at jerry's deli yeah who are now playing
arenas
in huge theater it's crazy but i love
that your dream you've overcome
the you basically achieve the impossible
it's crazy against all odds your talent
alone
tooth and nailed it and you're playing
an arena called the
smart financial center no it was
supposed
i think i'm doing like six legit arenas
on this tour
and each of them has a more preposterous
name than the next one
you're it's like when we put it on our
vision board we looked it was like you
know
uh madison square garden yeah yeah no
you know lubbock theater
it's literally just it's like union
credit bank arena
yeah and you're like it's vagisil wipes
theater yeah
it's like just like ah you finally got
there
and the names are so fucking
embarrassing and then the names are the
fucking dumbest
the pine-sol arena yeah and you're like
okay
i always think like the bank ones to you
like i don't want to be like have a bank
name
like don't remind people that they're
going into the center
pa with the bank that just over fucking
charge them yeah first union center fuck
first union dude
fucking first union center all the
places
that loan that i can't pay off now i'm
paying for tickets for their fucking
arena get their naming rights back they
obviously have fucking
my my fucking overcharge is paid for
this arena isn't it crazy though that we
can
that when you think about we were doing
bringer shows
you know what i mean and like main room
did you ever do dante shows canoga park
bowling alley i did
and um what was the other guy tk did you
ever do a tk show yes um
uh hold on was do you remember the one
that was out at a bar
the iron the something iron it was like
off an exit off like tampa
the grill iron there was a flat iron i
did a number of history with a fireplace
and you had to do a comedy next to a
fireplace it's a thing so he is just
thinking he's like you got to bring
10 people and i and this is like my
first i don't know they're basically
saying you need to lose 10 friends over
there yeah yeah and then
20 to watch you know you do
three minutes and mature like real
amateurs obviously
people come and they pay the 20 bucks
and then you realize oh like i didn't
realize oh it's like that's how
he makes it like that's how those
bringer guys make a living yes
and so i once one time of five yeah
i brought four because fifth couldn't
make it i couldn't go up oh yeah so
one time he i early on he was like who'd
you bring
and i was like like that guy he's like
it's not going to cut it man what do you
mean he's like
all right like you can give me 20 bucks
and like do the show and i was like
what like you want me to pay you then
and that's
when emily did her stand-up debut at the
wall she paid seven dollars
really emily's done standing well i
refused to and then he
and he was like well all right you can
go up last
and i was like close it out you mean
like i mean i was so new i didn't i
didn't even know what anything was going
on and then
and then he gave me a speech i still
remember he's like you need to treat
these shows like it's the improv
and i was like okay i mean i'm i'm
talking about like i'm like a year
understand i don't know anything and i
was like
you got it man like i'll treat i'll
treat this
bar show where everyone just paid you
like it's the improv that makes total
sense to me
but it at the time if you're like that's
only sure i can get on you and you do
end up perspective
there was a booker that i used to have
to pay for comedy lessons in order to do
his show
really i opened for a i'll tell you
afterwards
a big comic like like but not
no listeners here really know him but he
was big when we were coming up
club guy live act and i was his opener
i had no idea what it meant to be an
opener i had no money i knew i was
getting paid 300
didn't cover hotel didn't cover flight i
had to bring his
merch which was an 80 uh
pound box or fucking roller bag
this was back when you had to pay for 60
for the luggage you had to pay for it
yes and i picked up his kids every day
from school
what this is a comic you opened for yep
you guys tell me who this is and i will
and um uh afterwards
uh i would sell the merch and do the
credit card and i'd have to go on stage
and like do all the merch
because i would like lose 100 every time
i did it and then i get an overcharged
fee and then i'd have to sell on my
clothes at buffalo exchange to get the
money
like i was just like but i all i wanted
was the fucking stage time like i was
like where can i get to where the show's
good
i have to fly to the magic bag
in detroit or royal oak and
emily's gotta water for you okay she's
anticipating your every name and um
what what fucking choice do i have it
was before the internet was sure to
start a podcast
like good i don't know i don't remember
i was unconscious
you know and then how about this before
i went on stage it was
no crowd work no sex jokes
no relationship jokes and no dirty jokes
and i'd be like i am not i would just go
on stage and just like improvise
and just bomb and you know it shows you
though that people that like that like
the person telling you with those rules
they don't end up they're operating
that's all those
rules are out of fear and like it just
shows you that fear
based instructions lead to your like
your own demise
and if you're if you've been doing it
that long and are selling out the stuff
you're selling out
if if i if your opener has a
relationship joke
that you can't follow yeah
take a good hard look i want my openers
to be as funny as fucking possible
absolutely because you want the
show to be of value like when you buy a
ticket to my show i don't want you to be
like
well thank god you got up there yeah i
want you to be like tonight was awesome
yeah
when people because i just had zayad
with me i just said ronan from new york
with me
people were like dude your opener was
fucking amazing the tags would have me
in it and him and that's my dream
you know is that something like benton
it was fucking hysterical like i want
you to discover a new person tonight
because then in 10 years when they're
big they go i fucking saw them with them
i understand that benton to stand up i
found him at nashville
zany's nashville he came to the show and
he
uh came up to me in the book signing
line and was like hey i just
you know wanted to say hi i'm you know i
like you whatever and i was like oh do
you want a picture and he was like oh no
no i don't need a picture no get a
picture come on buddy
and then he was like oh no i'm good and
i was like what do you do like
trying to just give a fan time and he's
like oh i must do stand up
okay yeah and i was like oh shit i'm
sorry and
why don't you open for me uh tomorrow
night uh and do or do a guest spot i
think kevin christie was with me
and then he did a guest spot fucking
killed in a way that i was like
oh i don't know if i can fucking follow
this you know from
nashville killing luke bryan was in the
audience like came to see the show with
his wife and all their friends and i was
like
um and was so amazing i just brought him
on the road to open with me for like a
year
wow yeah that's cool i didn't realize it
was a comic the best i didn't know
the best so fucking funny and i'll just
say
one last thing he comes from actual life
experience
he worked at sephora he worked it he
worked in customer service he's done all
he's worked in like nursing home
bookings like so many of his stories i
forget that for art to imitate life you
have to have a life and
for us to be funny we have to keep
fucking being in the world
you have to participate in life he has
these jokes about working at sephora
yeah that are and i'm like fuck you you
to me if comedians have worked jobs that
aren't comedy
that's like the equivalent of like
doping in sports yeah or like being
molested like you're cheating
like you know so it's like he's got
these stories these crazy customer
service
stories where you're just like fuck i
need to like do another job for a while
so i can
stay funny that's what my one of the
things i learned about
you know myself touring for this long i
mean i've been
touring like as a feature i started in
06 featuring
around the country was there someone you
majorly did it for the most i did it the
most
for jay moore then joe and then russell
peters
yeah so those were the guys i i worked
with the most blue
bless you which is so amazing because to
work in arenas
and learn how to fucking work arenas and
then be able to do it
yeah so you're not all of a sudden an
arena and you've never fucking done one
before yeah
yeah yeah no and those guys there's a
lot of people those guys and then
ticket buyers do not come back no i know
if you fucking don't know how to do that
right but um
wait what was i telling you forget uh
that you when you were featuring
now that you've been touring only but
your features this is the thing i
learned is that
it's very easy especially if you're
exhausted to just go i do the show
i go to the hotel the next day i get on
the plane i go to the show i go
and what happens is if you do that long
enough you're not
participating in life nope and so when
people like cause i used to do this
thing like people go
you should check out i got i'm good you
need to go see the thing i'm fine
and i realized that if you if you do
that all the time you don't have
anything to talk about
yeah it's not doing anything you do make
um fucking brutal mistakes uh
threatening life changing and or ending
mistakes like i did
when i was in dallas and i had just been
going from club fitting to venue to
venue to venue and i went
good night houston
it was so emily was there it was so bad
i had to like
step back because that's like you like
republican and democrat level yeah and i
had to get them back
it took like 20 minutes and then say
good night dallas like
and i now try to i don't know how you
would possibly this time i try to fly in
a day early
and spend a day in the city yeah so that
i'm like this happened i learned this
and it's so good for you it's better for
you if you're a comedian to
experience life like you are essentially
somebody that reports on your life
that's right so if you
if your life is like i stay in hotels
i mean there's not that much and i only
fly private
and i know think about all the comedians
that we love
that got so successful and they went
sequestered themselves in their big
mansions in malibu or whatever and
you're just and then you see them
perform you're like
this is so wildly out like what's the
deal with having four butlers and you're
like
that's not jerry seinfeld by the way
that was literally just my dumb guy
voice
like just the idea of like you can't
everyone's like
you cannot relate to our problems yeah
you you can be unrelatable and if you're
also just like
and you know who fucking does live their
life and it pays off is larry david
yeah he can comment he can uh make
observations about things that it's like
how the fuck did you
relate because he gets dirty yeah he
goes and
leaves the tip himself and uses his
credit card i was in a while i was going
on a walk
in his neighborhood not knowing that i
was and this guy
young guy he's like hey man he goes
you're you're one of my favorite
comedians and i go oh
cool he goes this is larry david's house
and i go oh
he goes dude larry david lives here i go
you don't have to keep saying it
and he was like isn't that crazy though
like you're a comedian he's a comedian i
go no that's not crazy at all
and he goes dude you're like i can't
believe you're here
and larry david is right there and i was
like he makes it sound like i'm looking
for him
and i'm not and he's like well i'm just
saying and then if you're like yo
yeah i'm like all right man i started to
walk away from the house i feel like
he's gonna hear
you saying it to me and think that i've
been looking for him and he's like
he's like no i walk down the street
and i walk back he goes larry david i
was like dude fucking amen
so when next time he sees larry david
he's you know dude
also i'm obsessed with someone's first
gut reaction is to when they see you
yeah
uh and like what that says about how
they
uh uh because when someone's taken off
guard and they just see you yeah
and if they just go bull hog or like you
know what i mean
what they say so for me i'm always
fascinated when someone just uh
comes up to me and they're whatever
their experience is in life i can learn
so much about
them when they just go oh my god winnie
cummings i love margaret cho
and you're like what like just that's
that's the thing that's it remember when
we were emily walking
we were walking around austin we were
lost uh
we walked around the block six times to
find a car that was you know we passed
it was embarrassing but um this woman i
walked by and she went
and then she just went good comedy
and i was like that could have gone so
poorly
oh yeah you know what i mean thank god
she thought good comedy but she
said what came to her and didn't edit
herself she just could have been like
overrated yeah yeah yeah not a fan
yeah like emily you ever had somebody be
like
where you know i'm a pretty reasonable
person i think i have like a pretty good
sense of
i agree judgment and like i'm dialed in
i feel like i'm realistic you know i'm
not like a delusional person and
oh you proposed to christina yeah she
said yes so
i just you ever have like whatever
you're on a flight
or at a restaurant and you're like
i i really feel like this server or this
flight attendant or someone
is is like being rude to me like doesn't
like me
and it's and at first you're like and
then like you watch them like
pleasantly serve somebody else and then
they come over to you and they're like
anything else and you know i'm like what
the fuck and then it took me a while to
go like
oh i i feel like they don't don't like
they seem like me to stand up or
something they saw a special they don't
like a joke
and i it took me a while to figure out
that that like otherwise i'm like why
are you being
rude to me you know like i've had a
couple flight attendants where like
they serve everyone pleasantly and then
they're like
i was like yeah i was gonna eat uh later
and they're like no
no we're done serving and i'm like okay
and you know i mean like where you go
like
and it occurs to me that the person
doesn't i think they just don't like
what i do
and they have a bad you know have had a
bad reaction to it and that's all i can
put together can i tell you what's
happening
sure what i believe is happening i i
believe a lot of people
um you know i haven't listened to every
episode of your podcast so maybe they do
hate you with good reason sure but
a lot of times the people that are the
rudest rudest to me in public
are trying to play it cool quote unquote
and they're like
hey like i don't give a shit about
famous people like
i'm not gonna so instead like they want
so badly to not kiss your ass and
treat you differently that they over
correct and are rude that's interesting
and it happens a lot where people just
like hey
and i'm like you're saying hi to all the
other strangers coming in here and
they're like
look i don't care about famous people
like just so you know i know who you are
but like
i don't really think and then you're
like you do know me and that's totally
fine
yeah and we didn't start doing this to
not have people go hey love you're
a big fan yeah yeah so it's like i also
see it with sometimes when people are
here and i have famous guests in
like someone that's visiting try to play
it extra cool i see them go like
hey and i'm like say hi that's that's
a famous person that wants to be and
well i don't want to fucking them to
think that i like but i'm kissing their
ass stop
them and you're like no no no famous
person is bummed when someone recognizes
this
no no no and especially if you're not
but like the thing that
struck me a few times i'm like i'm like
i know i'm not crazy this person's being
like
a dick to me you know like like a at a
restaurant or something like why are you
being an asshole yeah
so maybe one of their family members was
in one of the videos that you play in
your live show that's true
now that could be it i i maybe their son
was one of the crazy weirdos that you
constantly play on your show
yeah my son is the smoke meth guy and
you keep playing his clip on your show
you know who who taught me about that
and sorry to name drop
but howard stern so people would just be
like
anyway and he was like what like you'd
obviously know me you i you know or
they'd be like no he's fucking dick like
just based on our personas or something
they said we have to assume
that not everyone has seen everything
we've done like of course there are
still some people that have only seen my
rose
of course they're like hey cunt and i'm
like oh yeah you know but
oh you haven't watched everything i've
ever done
why am i so fucking narcissistic to
think like no you've seen that i've
grown
yeah you've seen that i apologize for
some you know to p.m anderson or
whatever
but i do think a lot of people this is
my cause
is to tell people like recognize famous
people and and you're not no one
no famous person is going to have
someone be rude and then go
see they don't give a fuck about
celebrities love that guy yeah
that you know what i mean they don't
recognize me cool yeah you just maybe
just go like
you just gotta treat them like a normal
person yeah they're just people
yeah but i think people also when
they're nervous people do weird shit
that's true that's true because when i
met margaret atwood i
you freaking i was insane really insane
i started crying
and i said get away from me you're
margaret atwood and i don't want to
waste your time
because like she's getting old and i was
like i she's writing the next handmaid's
tale like
don't talk to me yeah she's like well
i'm a fan and i was like no no i don't
want to waste your time you're margaret
atwood
and then she's probably like what like i
acted crazy i still remember
when i did do a meet and greet once
where this guy uh was in the line and he
goes fuck you
and i was like what and he goes
uh i don't know i didn't know what to
say i was like that's what you went with
though
like fuck you he's like i didn't know
what to say maybe they have tourette's
and you're a bully yeah that's true and
the
last thing um uh what is the thing oh
when people will come up to me and
they'll go like guys especially which is
why i'm always trying to like dismantle
things about guys so that they don't
feel like they have to be like this
tough bullshit
fight club person yeah um where uh
because guys have pressure put on them
too defending the white male
per usual no but um but there are all
these fucked up things that guys like
guys will come up to me and they're
some of them are embarrassed that they
listen to my podcast or whatever a lot
of guys listen to this to go like oh i
just learned about women or i just yeah
or like they're not sexist and they
fucking like the show sure they just
like you
i have great guests or whatever but guys
will come up to me and they'll go hey
i don't know who you are but my
girlfriend loves you i'm not a gay
so okay so can we take a selfie and send
it to my girlfriend i'm just like
now i just feel like shit like i'm
posing for this thing and you're like
i don't know you are like you and you're
just like okay it's just kind of this
thing i'm like what's going on with you
that you have to neg me
yeah oh they you know what i get all the
time it's one of my favorites
like just like really puts me in my
place a guy i'll be like oh my god
i wanna take a picture and i'm uh i'm
like okay yeah sure
take a picture and he's like babe and
she'll go like i'm good
and i'm like you know what she's like no
she might
she might be going babe let's not waste
his fucking time now a lot of times
they're like ah
i'm fine and he'll be like no no get in
here she'll be like i'm really good
because
probably but maybe she's about to break
up with him
true and doesn't want to photo then
because you know how guys sometimes
or girls whatever i was in a
relationship where a guy kept fucking
planning vacations
like three months in advance whenever
he'd feel i was gonna break up with him
oh so if he posted a photo so if she was
in a photo
when she was in a photo yeah with the if
you and him
true and she couldn't if she posted or
he posted it that's another six months
in this fucking relationship because
it's time
that's a very hopeful and kind way to
look at the situation i like to always
look at the things very sweet way of
looking at it i think
picture but if i also if i saw even if
they had the best version of ever
if i saw a guy go hey tom let's take a
selfie i'd break up with him on the spot
so she probably was like oh we're done
you'd break again
because they bothered someone oh i got
you i guess and they were entitled
like when there's certain behaviors in a
relationship where if i see it
i can't get over it i did this in a
couple specials ago i was madly in love
with the guy
we were in new york we were walking
across a cobblestone thing and he
tripped and fell
and i was done just seeing him tripping
no that's horrible
it's you would definitely break up with
me
like this guy went to jump and fucking
almost lost his life i know but you've
been so rich for so long
um no i'm joking but no it was just
something it wasn't meant to be
when you leave a relationship for
something arbitrary like he fucking
didn't put the cap on the toothpaste if
it was right he tripped
if it was right that would not have made
me fall out of love with him okay
um i swear he also wore fucking
weird shoes that made him trip
that i already hated okay i'm saying but
it's the kind of thing where it's
it's if it's if it's minutia
and you leave because of it the whole
thing was off and you were looking for
that
i wasn't dating this girl but i remember
there's only something about behaviors
where you're like oh my god
uh i was at in paris at dinner with uh
las vegas paris france and uh
oh one the the server comes up and a
american woman who i was with goes
english
and i was like it sometimes takes one
thing oh my god
so i my dude that i'm with it's your
fault we
met during the pandemic we were together
nine months
before we ever went out in public
together okay
we we hadn't been on a date this was
wait this is the rock climber at the vet
yeah he we had never been out so we
i realized oh my god we haven't been on
a fucking date we haven't gone to a
restaurant
what if he's fucking rude to wait stuff
that's my number one thing yeah i've
i'm now he's living here we're in love
fuck
like i was infatuated with a woman who
was a model
a model 20 years ago i went out with her
and
she was so rude in a in a moment too i
almost missed it if i hadn't
missed it so i was just like i thought
this was this woman i was like
i've never seen i was just like just so
infatuated with her
gorgeous i pick her up
i can't believe i'm on a date with her
like that low i was like i can't believe
him she had a bad childhood
she uh she we she just
like dismissed the uh the parking
attendant
in such a way where i was like oh and
like my
level of attraction just went like like
the ten is a six
yeah i just sat there like i remember at
dinner i was like i can't like
i just i got a peek into who she was
like authentically with that and i
i couldn't shake it i couldn't this is a
woman who i was like if you would ask me
i'd be like i'll
propose were tomorrow the number one i
believe way
to tell who someone is is number one
what they do when they think no one's
looking
and number two the way they treat
someone who's i'm not saying the valet
was beneath working
but ostensibly working for you the way
you treat them
and we went to so we went on this like
fancy vacation because i was like
uh like i was just whatever a vacation
at a place that's overpriced
i really wish you hadn't given me this
it's so delicious it's a it's literally
um
mcdonald's mcflurry and so i
took him i uh we we went i can't say
things like that just because i pay the
bill i cannot say that
we went together i think you did all
right
i took him on this trip can't say that
no no no that girl we went on a trip
he went you went on a trip that he
planned i'm working on not saying my
house
oh that's a thing i'm working on him i
used to have to get that
i i was chastised about that yeah she's
like you're married it's ours
it's ours it's ours when i say like
stuff like that i'm really working on it
my dogs my house
uh the trip i took him on just because i
paid for it it's still ours
getting there even though it fucking
kind of looks a little
poke you know on the side um and uh
we get there and i was like we have to
do this whole
like going on a date for the first time
somewhere else so we i can just see what
the fuck happens
you know like we're going on our first
date and we've been together a year
and the moment where the waitress came
over our first time ever in public
and i'm like what if he's rude to the
white staff what if he's fucking rude i
have to go home tomorrow like i'm gonna
have to get a plane and then i'm gonna
have to get him out of the house and
what the fuck am i gonna do now i'm back
on raya like i was totally just like
spiraling
i'm gonna have to get my sperm should i
yeah yeah yeah right it's like okay let
me talk to brennan if
shop if he wants to platonic give me
some sperm and i bet his wife would not
like that like he's my tallest friend
like i always went into the worst case
scenario and where the fuck am i gonna
bring my dogs now that he's not my vet
anymore
this woman comes over she's probably in
her 60s she walks up and she's got she's
a career waitress
nothing i love more than a career
waitress
with the lipstick and i am fucking my
face is fucking bad
at the greeting you know she's what's up
the hair is up she's got her fucking pad
out
she writes down everything yeah she's
not like i got it i memorized it
like no like she's fucking got her
little flip pad 900
pence and her little thing comes over
and then she's got her custom pin
let's be dazzled because she's so
fucking committed to this job
and i'm like it's it's like happening so
much i'm like what if he's weird about
his favorite she comes over and he goes
hey linda how are you tonight you look
gorgeous
he's fully just flirting with her yeah
and i'm like oh my god not only
is he polite but he's flirting with
older waitresses
i was like i was just like it was the
hottest thing i've ever seen sure she's
like what do you want to see he's like
what do you recommend what do you like
like it was so cool yeah it's what you
want yeah
people like when you see the way someone
treats like the janitor
the you know i mean the the the server
the parking person that's who they are
you know that's it that's who they are
yeah and then whenever what people want
to come at me and to talk shit about
comics that are rich and famous
and they're like this person's an
asshole i'm like i saw them for 10 years
straight give 100
to the valet guys yeah so and they don't
talk about it so fuck off
yep you know like that's my like number
one gauge
good one why are you here why are you in
la because my austin studio is still
under construction so i've done
i'll end up doing uh you're banking them
here
yeah i end up doing recording 10
podcasts this week here
and there it's right down the street at
that place down the street and then
i'll come back for a couple days in july
and then
is christina not gonna be here for the
well because she got injured so so
she we had a studio set up at the house
with like these the guys who are
doing the tech at our studio came to the
house and set up a temporary thing for
her so she was able to did you have miss
pat
fill in the shit it'd be great
um but no hopefully like by
sometime in august or september i won't
have to do the back and forth so much
but i still you know i still come out
here a lot it's like kind of it's it's
nice to be on a plane after not being on
tv
austin's two and a half hours it's a
joke you know where i want to go is
marfa
in texas have it's a place that's like
the small town in texas that's like an
artist town and they have
have you ever seen that like prada store
in the middle of nowhere yeah
that's it that's i've heard of this it
has these crazy and they did that
just because they knew it would be a
fucking mind fuck to people right it was
just
kind of fantastic a bunch of cool
weirdos going let's make this crazy
fucking art in the middle of the desert
that's three hours
it's a legit prada store though right oh
i don't think it is that i don't know
the answer to that
i thought it was i heard i heard about
this did you buy something from there in
the package
doesn't come yet no no no no no wait i
someone told me it was a real
story who did i give all that money to
on reddit i feel like that that that's a
i heard that that's a glitch and i was
like at first i was like what
and then i thought about it i was like
that's kind of rad to pick like a
random in the middle of nowhere and put
a incredible high-end
like designer scene
and then there's a uh like a huge
mirrored
house and there's just like all this
cool shit and i i do next time i come to
austin i want to just like make a day
trip out of it yeah you gotta you gotta
come over when you come to austin yes
please
yeah my pig lives in best strip okay
mm-hmm
well you can come check out my fence
it'd be real nice we're not you're not
we need i love here's what i love about
you i love
that you are so salty the earth and
you don't realize how many people are
currently taking advantage of you and
lying to you
and stealing from you and how they will
continue to maybe i get it more because
i'm a girl
yeah but i had a i'm gonna take some of
your advice but
i have questions for you when this ends
but i i remember one time i had um
the last house that i lived in uh uh
there was a lot of bad work done
coincidence that tim allen lived there
before me not sure
uh but he would basically he came up to
me one time at
uh starbucks and i was like hey i live
in your old house
you know and he was like oh the place
was shithole i was like yeah cause you
did the work
you're an actor you're acting like a
handyman yeah
and so yeah and so yeah pam anderson was
your tool guy
yeah um but uh but anyway so the house
had all these problems and
there was a leak under the patio
from the from the pool so the pool
would leak into the there was a crack
and it would go
under the patio which was going to go
under the house disaster
okay yeah so uh i call someone out
to help me like this is the guy that
comes and does it he says this is three
three hundred thousand dollars what the
fuck because you have to tear this whole
thing up we have to go under the house
get the mold if there's mold we have to
see if there's not enough
and then i had this handyman that i used
forever this guy gary butters who's this
older guy
remember gary butters never carry
butters
he was a hundred and fifty and
uh and he he wouldn't let me pay him
remember he wouldn't let me pay him ever
ever
he i tried to give him a check he
wouldn't take it he was crushing on you
he would come over and do work and not
let me pay him yeah or he'd say 20 bucks
and i'd be like i cannot pay you 20
bucks to fix my entire kitchen like
and i loved him so much and i would
sneak ways to pay him and stuff but he
came out and i was like hey they just
told me this is gonna be 300 thousand
dollars i got to do it like that's true
i got to do about 5 000 casinos he went
oh no no you just lower the level of the
pool water and we lower this we shave
an inch off this rock that's keeping the
level high
and then he did a test to find where
there was a crack in the pool
that was going under he goes and then we
just pace this up with something from
home depot
it was forty dollars he did it yes so it
really was like 20 bucks
yes yeah and it fixed the problem that's
amazing so if you're you it's going to
cost
300 grand if it's you know what i mean
they people will take advantage of us
and that's fine we have the best life in
the world we
get the best job in the world it's a
small price to pay it's a small price
bay but
yeah i mean you need a gary butters
though to fucking now dude
we gotta find one we
i'm worried he's dead he used to be adam
corolla's main
uh handyman oh he's got to be good then
he does oh
he would build like standards are high
he'd build like
a bar in his pool and bridges you know
the sweetest
like little thing to put your computer
on
like so she wasn't like bent down and it
was just like beautiful
and great like a drawer with a jewelry
box
and he used to drive hours to come to
your house
i know and then his his um his
german shepherd was blind and it got
loose and i don't think he found it
every time he'd come in there'd be some
horrible thing that happened
gary butterstone i i know i was like i
was hunching over my computer all the
time and he
built me like a like a dollhouse box
that's cute with a little drawer shout
out to gb man dude
you nee you need we need people in our
lives i have
i have one now that's pretty amazing
it's heartbreaking when
someone uses you but it's the deal
yeah it doesn't just happen that's
happens to everyone i know i know i'm
going to ask you about a couple hires
that i want to make and get your advice
yeah just go on taskrabbit and knock
that shit out okay
okay all right you're not fucking tom
cruise okay
okay you're the tom cruise of podcasting
but um
i love you well i end these very
awkwardly and you're a pro so i'm
embarrassed
well i love you too and um thank you for
having me i'm super impressed with your
setup um
it's super fun i'm so glad that you took
this and ran with it you know
i'm so glad that you guys inspired me uh
to do it
by having being so bad at it that i
could be like well i could do that yeah
of course
that's that's the way people do things
but no i have to say that
that because this is make me emotional
you know and we didn't talk about our
acting careers but yeah i spent so much
time like
destroying myself and um being like
heartbroken and insulted by oh i'm 35
now i play a mom
or 28 i was getting a mom probably i'm a
mom now i'm not pretty enough now i'm
too old now i have to get a fucking uh
i had a network tell me i had to cut the
bags out of my eyes and get botox like
i was like i don't really have a plan b
and i'm doing stand-up and what if i
decide to have a family i have no backup
plan
and there's nothing more terrifying than
that feeling that's a terrifying feeling
that's why i didn't
well we didn't start a family um until
like
we felt some stability and even though
this is the most unstable career you
could get into like
doing something else like this is
totally even though they're connected
separate from
but you guys inspired me to take matters
into my own hands and go
okay no one is going to do this for me
no no one is all these agents and
managers good intentions but they're not
and then look what's happened so then
you're just in charge of your own thing
and then yeah and and i remember let me
just tell you one more thing
you called me once because a lot of
times people call me for advice and i
end up getting the most out of it
you also showed me like walk away from
something even if it's what you've been
dreaming of for 15 years and
isn't the right dream to have anymore
you don't go well i've always wanted
this and now it's here
the deal's bad it's not a good idea but
i've always wanted to have my own show
and now i have it but the circumstances
are completely fucked and wrong for me
now yeah
and you call you and christina call me
about a some tv show
you know you have millions of offers and
it was just like you're like yeah we're
going to walk away from this
dude can i tell you that it's happened
multiple times now where i go
oh someone wants to do this this show or
something
and it'll be with like really reputable
like you know the people you want to
work with
and as it gets closer to happening i'll
get these like things where i'm like
man i don't even know if i want to do
this you're the value in it
when you when you when you don't when we
don't update our software
and get our fucking self-esteem together
which is our job to do to go wait a
second
yeah it used to be i'm the lowest on the
totem pole in this show
now they need me yeah it's a weird place
and then you when you like i remember
like figuring out one time that like one
of these shows i
i pulled out i was like i don't want to
do it and the relief that i felt and it
wasn't because like oh i don't want the
pressure of the show
i just was like i don't want to i don't
want to give my time to this and i was
like
oh but what i'm doing is what i really
want to do i'm already doing it
and i really enjoy doing what i'm doing
the podcasting is stand up
to me is actually very fulfilling for
some reason it wasn't that mark wahlberg
movie
yeah i mean mark was great i'll say that
i know
i'm joking uh but i think
you know i i like the feature schedule
i've done a few
small things yeah you are like such a
fucking good actor
really yes you're like jim gaffigan
where i'm like what the fuck what have
you seen
me in uh a movie about cell phones that
killed people oh yeah
and by the way i just thought it was so
funny you know when you get an offer did
you audition for that or they just
offered it
just offered it when you look at the
name of the straight offer
yeah it was just derek yeah yeah he's
shoeing
yeah yeah yeah mine is always like
some kalian like and you look at it and
it's an offer and you're like oh the
crazy prostitute extra like straight off
her
you're like i'm finally getting offers
and they're all insulting
i i like it i do like it i like acting i
don't
really like the development process or
especially for television there's it's
it's not
it's not a real process it's a fake
process
i mean i i i would do more of the
features because it becomes about
feelings and egos
and something humans i think are really
bad at is we don't know how to cut our
losses
we go i've been in this relationship for
four years it's going bad but i've spent
four years on it right
most of the development processes this
isn't working
now we see that this idea that sounds is
not sustainable it's not executable it's
not good the team's wrong
fuck it we've already spent six months
on it and just yeah let's just do it we
ha
like i never know when to fucking call
it yeah and i wasted two years
truly two straight years working with
people
that they were my hero and they wanted
to work with me
yeah and i was like i didn't know my own
value or my
have respect for my time so i was like i
have to work with them and then it was
like ah how do i get out of this
yeah and i can't i don't know how to cut
my losses and i don't
i'm too afraid to say no what if no one
ever works with me again
what if no but when you say no
ironically the phone starts ringing up
the hook it's the craziest it's so weird
that's like an old cliche but most
powerful word
is no yeah we're defined by the things
we say no to not the things we say yes
to and like
it's such a weird eye still though if i
get a fucking tv show or a movie
or an audition for something big i will
drop everything i'm
finally the point where i'm like i'm not
rescheduling the podcast i'm not
rescheduling stand up
i almost moved a date to be in a tv a
stand-up date and i was like why am i
still
letting them destroy my life i just i
just got a call about a movie
and they're like it starts shooting like
two days after my tour starts
and i was like well then i can't do it
and they're like really
what are you paying me i was like dude
you're paying me what's oh sag scales
look at this tour man like
you think i can like just move this
around you're asking all these people
that bought tickets i was like there's
no way
and he goes well what if i go look at
the schedule if you think it can fit in
the days off and that
go and he was like i don't think it can
work i was like of course it can't work
and then he's like what about i go look
man here's a schedule way in advance
when you see it open up that's when i
can do something like this i'm not
moving this around
this isn't a like with touring you have
like your down year
where you're like you know working on
stuff figuring out and then you're like
i'm touring i'm like i'm not screwing
that up these dates were made and by the
way this venue
like i have a relationship with these
people i made a promise to these people
it's not the fucking haha man
like it's credit union bank arena
like there's literally the uh
thousands of people have been planning
for like
changed around their schedule people
also people are in hotels for this
i had a fucking crazy uh
wake-up call this past weekend when half
the people drove seven hours
and because i was talking to people
afterwards and like i flew here from
this is that crazy
you got a hotel room to cut you flew
here for this show
and i almost cancelled it yeah to do a
youtube show i always canceled it to do
an em
a peacock guest star i know it's wild
and you and
that's what i told me one time they go
what's the thing that like
amazes you the most about having someone
come and they go it's like they're
buying the ticket and i go no
that's not the crazy part the crazy part
the part that makes me go wow
is that somebody gave me all that time
like they have a day
and they go i'm going to leave my house
but like i'm going to spend basically
you know it's not the time that you're
just on stage the whole time of getting
there
being out and then they show up in your
merch like you ordered it ahead of time
so it will come in time
that's like holy shit this person gave
like all this time to come see me i get
lots of like bachelorette parties and
girls nights and stuff and i was at the
venue this past weekend
and i looked at this table of literally
it was like 30 people and i was like
how many emails had in text had to
happen for this to be coordinated all
right
like i was like for me to wrangle 30
because of my girlfriends
giving you so much by doing they had to
go okay i'll pay for the tickets you'll
we'll do memo i'll pay you back i'll pay
for the like and then i'm gonna go like
why am i still like but in any movie
that no one's ever gonna see
just asked me and i'm gonna cancel
everything like why are we still
do that movie when it fits for you yeah
you know which was why i think if you're
going to do it you should maybe direct
it
it will actually be easier i'm not
kidding really because you get to set
the schedule
you get to change stuff around you'll
still lose people last minute that
happens with everyone you know when i
did a movie i lost
an actress two days before to some crazy
family tried to recast it like there's
always going to be
always something that comes up but but
when a movie tells you they're gonna get
you out by four
to get on your plane at five to get to
vegas and get to your mirage show at
seven you are not
going to get out no i i did it every
fucking time
and then i couldn't do my coverage and i
could only be white shots and i had to
leave a set
because i just i told you they're always
going to go over it's oh by the way
here's the other thing
you're going to cancel credit union
arena whatever the fuck to do that movie
and then their schedule will change oh
right it won't be that day
oh hey we had to move it for another
actor you can actually go ahead and do
that arena and you're like um
it's not that easy to rebook man iron
maiden's there now i love
i love your uh
annoyed face it's so it's the best meme
on the planet is you going like
[Laughter]
it's so fucking funny they see it a lot
at home
when when one of the great joys you guys
are like
last thing we grew up on multi sitcoms
and stuff like my favorite show ever
growing up do not take this as an insult
was married with children
yeah and when there's a dynamic and
theirs was obviously so broad and
whatever at the time
but i'm always like who's the new you
know
um sonny and cher who's the new i love
lucy like what's because everything's
just taking a place of something that
went away yeah you know like what's the
new sex in the city what's the new this
like who's the new howard stern who's
the new whatever i think that's
maybe you but having christina's not
really a robin
right you guys sort of feel a little bit
like al and peggy
just in terms of your like any time
you're annoyed with each other it never
feels like you actually don't like each
other right it doesn't feel like
contempt
ever no it never feels like bickering
yeah and
they the great sitcoms mad about you
were able to do that of like
you're always frustrated never annoyed
yeah or i'm sorry like it's all or maybe
it's annoyed me i'm frustrated i don't
know
wisdom versus knowledge i don't have
either so you'll you have the ability to
go like uh
but we know you still love it yeah you
know it's not like hate to stay
so rare yeah you're right it's like i
think you have to have real love to be
able to i don't do double dates because
five literally five minutes in they
start fighting silently like oh you're
gonna order the salmon why not okay fine
we're the same again
and you're like why am i sitting here
through watching you guys hate each
other even though you're pretending you
like each other
yeah call it this is why i don't like i
don't like like podcasts with like five
people i'm like nah dude i just wanna
like
it's you will be oasis in two months
dude you guys are gonna be if you make
it
you're the eagles yeah i agree you have
everything in the world and you fucking
hate each other
and you can't fake it for three hours
you cannot no don't do it
all right well do you have any questions
for me i think i i'm good
that's the girl that doesn't want the
photo with you i know
yeah no i'm fine i'm fine don't ride
elephants
um and give tom more money honestly he
deserves it
thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
you